Thank you.
What's going on, man?
We don't draw a huge crowd, and my co-host hasn't shown up yet, so I think we're in the
early stages here of the space.
Hey, Morgan, let me try to bump you up.
Let's see if we can do this.
All right, Morgan, I sent you the link for the co-host.
We'll see if we can make this happen.
All right, I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and
I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you
the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link
for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host, and I sent you the link for the co-host.
All right, the thumbs down means you didn't get it?
Let me try again.
All right, I sent it again.
You might have to, like, reboot.
We've been having tremendous technological issues.
We're not the paranoid type, so we're not ascribing it to some sort of non-human intelligence or anything like that.
We're just, I guess, on the edge of being boomers, although he's a lot younger than I am, technologically.
Okay, we've got you as a speaker.
Let's try this again.
Okay.
Because you know what's going to happen.
I'm going to get all wound up, right, and then I'm going to say something that I'm not supposed to say, and they're going to drop us again.
You know, the AI is just going to bail out on it in case there's something wrong, right?
Yeah, I'm not even getting co-host invites at all.
Son of a bitch.
Every week.
How much did the guy spend?
$42 billion, and he cannot make it work?
It's not your fault.
I'm just saying, like, what, you know?
Maybe the trajectory of most technology, and it's just degraded as time goes on.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think you're right.
I think that that's probably what's going on behind the scenes, where we see the appearance that everything is becoming more technological,
but the opposite is probably true, as is often the case.
I guess I'll just keep trying to send you the – because you know I'm going to get kicked, right?
This is just what happens.
So, I think we're going to do something different today.
Let's talk for a few minutes while we build up people before we jump into, like, me rambling on.
I wanted to key you into the fact that this is, like, we're touching on the paranormal.
We didn't have a chance because we got hung up on it, and I was on a wicked long rant, as we like to say in Massachusetts.
But I think we're going to cover, like – people have been talking about aliens, like, with us a lot online.
So, I thought that we would cover, like, what you guys – what you guys have found about the nature of aliens, right?
Well, as in me and us.
Well, us, but yes, but Intuitive Underground, like, specifically what you – right?
Because I have – right?
We've come to conclusions together, but you guys have some session data about the phenomenon that I think that is probably apropos to remind people, right?
Because not everyone listens to every space.
As a matter of fact, anytime we host a space, we may have people who haven't listened to the spaces where we've explained, like, what's going on with that.
Yeah, and now, another thing is, when we introduce ourselves, right, which is what we're doing now, while we're struggling to get you into the co-host position, I wanted to touch base with you.
When we say, like – and I explained, I'm JT, right?
I'm an astrologer, and Morgan here is a remote viewer, and he's – I guess I would call him the lead, but I guess maybe there are no leads in Intuitive Underground.
He represents Intuitive Underground, which is a group of remote viewers who have recently had – well, I guess you're still working on it – a 10-plus-year project called State of Reality, originally, now called The Canon Work, which was devoted to mapping the nature of reality, including a lot of paranormal themes, UFO stuff.
But it wasn't like a UFO-themed project that just sort of went along with the mapping of reality, right?
So, you should definitely – like, at the beginning, we should mention your website as well, for people who are interested in what you have to say about remote viewing and remote viewing training.
And it's – I'm going to give the wrong one, because I always do.
So, you've got to give the right one, dude.
Sure, yeah.
No, it's just remoteviewingtraining.com.
I don't know why I always think learn remote viewing at someone else's site, and I tell people.
I'm like, yeah, you've got to see my buddy Morgan.
Go to this site.
Yeah.
I don't know, dude.
I don't know why I have a – I've got to write it down.
It was literally Tom, so that's what we're thinking of.
Yeah.
I mean, you know what?
Yeah, we can talk about all that.
Can't say I'm overly prepared for that discussion.
I didn't really realize we were going that route today.
Which is – there's probably – well, there's almost certainly plenty of old session work that I haven't thought of or looked at in a long time.
So, I'm not sure how much of the detail I can get into, but sure.
Yeah, so I know Fringe wants to do a space focusing on the intuitive underground alien stuff.
I linked you in that conversation.
I don't know if you got it.
We should, like, I think, sort of take her up on it because of all the stuff that's going on right now, like, I think that it's a good idea to kind of keep at least her aspect of the room, you know, running.
That's my opinion.
So, we could definitely do that if you're willing to do it, but it would be, like, probably not on a Thursday.
So, we'd have to coordinate that with her.
And then you could get it all together.
However, like, before we get into, like, the aspects of human nature and the paranormal, we should at least address the fact that we believe we're living in a simulation, right?
I mean, that's, we should probably.
That's a good place to start.
Yeah, that's a good place to start.
Exactly.
And what was the other thing we had to get to?
Oh, yes.
So, when we talk about, when we do the introduction, right?
Now, we both worked on the Astro RV Project.
And it's an idea I believe we both had individually, but I don't think we're probably the only ones.
I think there are probably other people out there.
You're the person who made it happen, right?
Of anyone who's probably ever had that idea.
And so, I always think of it that way, that you're the person who made that happen.
However, when we're doing the opening to these spaces, like, it's an achievement to have created the Astro RV Project.
Although it's still in the infancy, right?
It's revolutionary.
So, you know, is it appropriate in your, you know, from your perspective for me to introduce it by saying that we are the originators or creators of the Astro RV Project?
Or do you think that that's deceptive and that you alone are the creator?
I mean, that's a legitimate question because I don't want to run into, like, any...
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I don't want to cause a rift.
Yeah, no, I mean, I'm not too fussy on that.
So, you think it would be a fair assessment to say that we're the originators of the Astro RV Project?
Well, yeah, I think the way that you described it is exactly correct from, I mean, not inside your mind.
I mean, I guess it could be, but...
Got it.
No, I wouldn't do that.
But, yeah, as I understand it, you know, it was just a...
It was a kind of a parallel line of thought.
And, I mean, I reached out to you and it sounded like you had already thought about such a thing.
And, I mean, to be fair, one of Ingo's books, Ingo Swann's books that I have sitting on my bookshelf that I've not read yet is...
Oh, which one is it?
I think it's your Nostradamus Factor.
And it's about, you know, predictive work, future seeing, that sort of thing.
That is how Nostradamus did it.
He did, like, an Astro RV thing.
But it was a seer thing, right?
He didn't have the protocols.
So, he used astrology and then he used a looking glass.
Sort of like a looking glass.
It was like a bowl filled with water, but it was a black bowl.
And he stared into that and he had his clear...
Yeah, his vision's that way.
Yeah, well, I...
Someone mentioned to me that Ingo kind of touches on the general concept somewhere in that book.
I don't think it was quite the same approach that I kind of came at it with just because of my own training and background.
But, yeah, I mean, I don't know.
I don't have to think about it.
That's cool.
I just wanted to make sure we were on the same page so that I wasn't causing any friction.
Yeah, I got you.
Don't worry.
Yeah.
All right, guys.
Sorry, we're going through that.
So, I'm JT and I'm an astrologer and I practice astrology in a different way.
Well, semi-practice now at this point in my life.
In a different way than other people do, than anyone else does.
Morgan is a remote viewer.
He is an expert in remote viewing and he runs Intuitive Underground, which is, in my estimation, the most important group of remote viewers in the world.
That's my personal opinion.
They have a 10-plus year project, the Canon project, where they have explored the nature of reality and they've done it in depth with a lot of session work.
And a lot of the session work, the targets they use are not leading targets.
So, a lot of the information that they've come up with has been completely incidental and unexpected.
But it's very important information.
We run these spaces.
He teaches remote viewing.
And, yeah, we're doing these spaces to sort of get everything out, get it recorded so we can go back and listen to it and see what we're going to do with it from this format of people asking questions and whatever.
Today, we're talking about human nature and the paranormal, and I think it's important that we begin by saying that both Morgan and I are of the opinion that we live in a false reality.
That's an important thing to get right off the bat.
We see things from the context based on personal experience and the Intuitive Underground session work.
We see things through the context of our living under what we would term to be a reality overlay.
So, you could use the term simulation, but it may be misleading because people associate simulation with something that's occurring inside of a computer.
You could use the term matrix, and it would probably be more accurate, but it's an often used term, and I think other people have control over the definition and the connotation of the matrix.
So, we would use reality overlay, which I believe came out of their session work.
So, everything we talk about, we're going to talk about from the position of before the reality overlay and after the reality overlay.
Today, talking about human nature is specifically we're looking at inside, we're mapping sort of inside the reality overlay and how it works.
However, from our position, this isn't a computer program, we're not making that argument.
We're making the argument that human beings exist, that human beings are material, that there is a real world and there is a real material world, which we refer to as base reality.
Our argument is that the world that we perceive is not base reality.
So, we don't argue that you're fake.
We don't argue that you're AI.
We don't argue that you're a being of light sent across the cosmos to go on some sort of corporate HR mandated vacation training program.
What we argue is very similar to what ancient Greeks and the ancient Indians and other cultures argued that we're not necessarily in this situation voluntarily.
And it was something that was sort of done to us at a point in history by a group of individuals history knows as the Archons.
We've done spaces about that.
It does tie into the UFO phenomenon.
However, from our perspective, we don't see the UFO phenomenon the way a lot of people in UFOX do because we don't, by definition, if we're living in a false reality, then the events that are occurring to us in this reality aren't real.
They're events that occur within our minds.
And so, what we are, what our position is, is that the reality overlay is something akin to a consensus dream that we are unable to wake up from.
However, the reason I talked to Morgan about, or I mentioned at the beginning here, that we should talk about the nature of aliens is that we do believe it is possible there is communication from without the reality overlay into the reality overlay.
And I think that some, but not all of the alien encounter and UAP experience, witnessing, whatever the official term is, represents communication between the two of one kind or another.
So, is my understanding, I just want to get this out of the way, Morgan, because people have brought it up, right?
So, it is my understanding that some, but not all of your session work would tend to indicate that a lot of what is witnessed or experienced as alien beings and alien craft could, in fact, be something that is from here, is put together here, but is put together by something outside of the reality overlay.
Is it an accurate statement?
By some way of putting it by some remote intelligence.
Okay.
So, you know, at that point we're thinking maybe, you know, someone from a, you know, some intelligence in a far off planet or galaxy or, or, or whatever.
It was really, you know, it was really, you know, it was really only later, you know, after we kind of, kind of gained a bigger picture in, you know, what we've been referring to as the canon project work, the, the nature of reality, that we realized that, okay, that remains a possibility in some cases.
However, with, you know, with this concept of, you know, with this concept of, you know, a base reality and a false reality overlay that we are stuck within.
That opens up an entirely new realm of possibilities with regard to, you know, external influences and that sort of thing.
So, yes, what you just described, I would, I would fully agree with.
And one metaphor or analogy, I guess, in this case, would be that they, that this, what we could be looking at is something like a virtual avatar.
Something that would be a vessel for an intelligence from a distant place, right?
Interacting in this world.
So you've been talking about distant planet, but what we could be talking about is like a sim, right?
In a sense, not exactly the same because we're not necessarily in a computer, right?
But along those lines, like this is the, the, the virtual avatar possibly of, of an extraterrestrial being or something.
So it could be a human being, could be an extraterrestrial being.
It could be something we don't quite understand.
It could be real aliens, but we're interacting with these virtual avatars that represent these intelligences.
We can't necessarily say exactly what they are.
That's part of the deception.
Is that a fair statement?
Oh yeah, very much so.
And I mean, you know, in, in some of our analysis, I mean, we've, we've used the, that exact term avatar.
Yeah.
I mean, I think that that's a fair assessment.
And I think that when, if you look at the phenomenon from that perspective, it unifies both the, the concept of like the, the crash saucers, right?
Which we all hear about, but I don't know, maybe someone here has held the metal in their hands, but I certainly haven't.
You know, crash saucer retrieval and using the alien technology and, and people, you know, having abductions and waking up and there's a, as a physical being in their room.
But that also would, would include the John Keel, Jack Filet, um, passport to Magnolia stuff, right?
Like the, it would be one reason why it would be such a strange phenomenon, in my opinion, um, without getting into necessarily like spiritual metaphysics, without talking about like, I mean, you could, but I think that would be one way of sort of explaining.
And if you think of how strange virtual experiences are for human beings, the oddness of what we create in the worlds that we create or the virtual worlds that we create, right?
Whether it's a video game or whether it's, I mean, I've never been in the, the metaverse.
I only know what I've like videos I've seen in the metaverse, right?
So I'm not talking from firsthand experience, but the videos I've seen in the metaverse, uh, and I haven't, I haven't watched them too closely.
I'm not a weirdo, right?
But there's, there's people walking around in there, you know, and they're like, uh, they're all some kind of dog or bear or something.
Right.
And, uh, Hey Morgan, can you take over for a second while I deal with this?
Just, uh, greet everyone and all that.
I got to deal with the, uh, the diabetes thing.
Yeah.
Sure thing.
So, uh, yeah, well, GT's taking care of that.
Um, yeah, I would like to say, you know, thanks to everybody for tuning in.
Um, I see we got science, Bob, how you doing?
Uh, Joseph, what's going on, man?
Uh, Sally, nice to see you.
We've got, uh, red palcoala or what the hell?
Red panda koala.
Sorry.
How's it going, man?
Um, Arden, Sadie, uh, Eric, Matthew, Bigfoot, bark like a duck.
Nice to see you, man.
And thoughtful of pearls.
How's everybody doing?
Hope you guys are having a good day.
So if you hear an alarm going off, um, I, I have this crazy situation going on right now
with a pet who had asthma and I treated it with steroids and the steroids gave them diabetes.
And I'm racked with guilt about giving the pet diabetes.
So I'm putting extra effort into taking care of them 24 seven.
And, uh, they have a, as strange as this is going to sound,
they have a blood sugar monitor and the blood sugar monitor goes off and I have to go in
and assist them with their blood sugar.
So it's, uh, I know that people disagree about the amount of effort people should put into
taking care of pets.
But in this case, um, I'm, I'm, I'm not one of those people, but definitely since I am the cause of this animal suffering, I, I need to, um, prioritize that.
I'm back.
I just had to go help them for a second.
Uh, yeah, so it, it, it, you know, cause you read like Jacques filet, right?
And you've got the, you've got these basically like these flying, uh, these flying pancake huts landing in the middle of nowhere prior to Roswell and making people potato pancakes, tasteless, uh, pancakes of some sort.
You have like, as strange as that's going to sound, right?
That's something that, that is, um, a topic in his work, right?
You have, um, now I, I was part of the full disclosure.
I was part of the, I got a fan or part of the UFO disclosure community in the nineties, uh, and have not been, uh, since that time.
Um, the last, I was trying to think about the last move on convention.
I went to, it was like, this is back like Eric von Daniken and Stan Friedman, uh, Jacobs were there.
Like those were the players at that time.
And it was sort of a different community because, uh, and this is no disrespect to anyone.
It wasn't really centered around whistleblowers at that time.
It was centered around guys like von Daniken.
Although, you know, you could Stan Friedman was debt was an intelligence agent.
So, um, so it's been a long time and I'm not, there's, I'm not, I'm not current sometimes with events that have occurred in ufology in the last 20 years.
Um, but these were things that we, we used to discuss back then.
You know, one of the things, topics we discussed back then is the, um, amazing amount of religious imagery that people have during abduction experiences, which is, I don't hear anyone talking about it in UFO X now.
Um, so I imagine the situation is the same as it was then, which was that it's just sort of omitted by UFO investigators, um, who deal with abductees.
Um, so when someone has an abduction, you know, at least they used to, right?
So this was 20 years ago.
So 20 years ago or more, when someone would have an abduction, it was not unusual for that abduction to feature the Virgin Mary.
You'd have, you know, gray aliens, you'd have reptilians, you'd have mantids.
And then all of a sudden there would be a visualization of the Virgin Mary and, and that would be part of the experience.
And then later on when it was reported, that was omitted from the, from the report that would make it into magazines.
And people would do some research at that time, um, you know, into that subject saying, look, I think, um, everyone here has probably read Gods of Eden by William Bramley, right?
That was, that was the classic, at least back then, like that was the, the classic on that subject.
Um, all of that could be metaphysically true, but from the perspective of the reality overlay, it's a lot easier to explain.
The reality overlay is pretty much like the greatest thing you can imagine from the perspective of Occam's razor, because it just makes sense, right?
When you find these like series of inexplicable weird things that people have to curate in order to take some of the weirdness out.
So that even the people who are fans of inexplicably weird things can be into it like that, that's metaphysically as difficult, right?
Like from a cosmological standpoint, like trying to put the universe together and say, well, we really have these, these insects coming from this planet.
And, you know, from the other side, we have got these clone people who are controlled by, uh, by an AI from another part of the universe.
And they're all coming here so they can sit in an operating room and diddle Whitley Strieber, right?
Now that's difficult.
And then if you add, well, and then there's the Virgin Mary was in the room next door, right?
Then it gets like, it's, it's, you know, who can, who can even imagine that?
Like it's cognitive dissonance territory, right?
However, if you have a situation where we're kind of stuck in this reality overlay and people from outside the reality overlay who are definitely not friendly to the human race are able to come here and muck around.
And suddenly everything from pedophile reptilians to, uh, strange, um, non-sequitur religious experiences and elves making pancakes in a hut, you know, outside someone's front door in the late 1800s.
And that all, that all sort of makes sense because it's, it's pretty much what like a bunch of dudes from 4chan will put together if they created their own universe.
Um, and so that's, that's what we talk about.
And today we're going to talk about, um, like some of the things about human nature that are different from what the average person knows and how that can sort of change the way that you look at paranormal encounters.
Uh, from this perspective, right, we've got a higher self, that higher self is our physical body outside of the reality overlay that higher self is also our unconscious mind.
The collection of those higher self beings networked together in a very physical way from, from, from our data are the collective unconscious.
Now, this is not against what Carl Jung said.
This is very much in line with Carl Jung's thinking.
He just didn't have the science fiction imagery, right?
But Carl Jung, the, um, archetypes, the synchronicities emerge, um, not from the collective unconscious.
That's a misunderstanding.
Carl said they came from an Unus Mundi, one world, that there was one real world that we're incapable of perceiving directly.
And the only way we're able to perceive that world at all is through the synchronicities and the archetypes that emerge from the Unus Mundi into our conscious awareness.
And the collective unconscious is the, the gate or bridge between the two.
So from our perspective, um, from our perspective, um, from our perspective, a lot of what is paranormal can, could be, right?
It could be archons mucking around.
If it's negative, it probably always is, but it, it can also be communication from our quote, higher self, our true self, our body outside of the reality overlay.
Um, or somebody else outside of the reality overlay.
Now this is paranoia territory.
We don't focus on it too much because we're not paranoid individuals.
You could go down this route and really let it consume you if you have like paranoid tendencies.
So if you have paranoid tendencies, you know, there are a lot of themes here that are triggering and we love you.
And, you know, we're glad that you tuned in, but you, you probably shouldn't listen on further because we can talk about this stuff.
And then go to dinner, take care of our pets, live our lives, go to work for those of us who have jobs.
We don't have any problem with that, but somebody with those tendencies, this, this could really be triggering.
And this could be something that could really derail you.
Right.
So we just always want to give that heads up before we get too far into it.
So from the perspective of the reality overlay, a lot of physical phenomenon, environmental phenomenon, even.
Right.
Are metaphorical representations of the collective unconscious.
So from our perspective, it's not just like an archetype of lightning that is part of the collective unconscious.
We see the entire reality overlay is existing within the minds of the individuals experiencing it.
So instead of a brainstorm being metaphorical, you know, what's going on in your mind, explained to a metaphor of what's going on with the weather.
Right.
We would look at that from the other perspective and say, you know, a storm could be metaphorical of what's going on with the networked individuals experiencing the reality overlay.
The Schumann resonance could be.
And this isn't in Morgan's work.
Okay.
This is, this is coming from me.
So don't blame Morgan for this, this stuff.
The Schumann resonance.
Someone asked me, what's the Schumann resonance?
Well, I think the Schumann resonance is the arc, the emerging archetype of the collective unconscious.
I think it is the, it's not material, but it is in a sense, part of the material world as, as that, as the resonance, as the frequency.
Um, and I believe that that is the, the way that we can view the collective unconscious here in this world is by, by looking at the Schumann resonance.
That's my personal opinion.
Now, I'm not saying the scientific, I'm saying that's the opinion that I've come to.
Uh, I'm not making arguments about being, um, you know, being a scientist because I'm not a scientist.
I try to think scientifically, but I don't know if I always succeed.
Um, when this all went down, this reality overlay situation, the archons, it was sort of the end of a long period, according to the data, it was the end of a long period of tampering or tinkering with human beings.
So I think Morgan's data, it doesn't mention Anunnaki.
Okay.
It doesn't specifically say ancient aliens.
I think it implies it, but I don't know if it specifically says ancient aliens, although it does involve, um, during the session data, correct me if I'm wrong, Morgan, during the session data involving the beginning alterations of human beings, there is a gray alien present as a prisoner on site.
Or something that you would describe as a, as a gray.
Um, yeah, I'm not sure I'd use the word prisoner, but I would say.
Oh, okay.
Present.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
No, that's why I asked you for confirmation because that's, that's important data, right?
Like I have only read the excerpts that are available on intuitive underground.com.
Um, of the, that session work.
I wasn't part of the session work.
I'm not a remote viewer.
So thank you for clarifying.
So there is, there are, what we would understand as extraterrestrials present at that time.
I know that the individuals that are responsible for tinkering with the human beings originally are described as quite stocky.
They don't have great descriptions of them, to be honest.
Um, it wouldn't surprise me if it's not the same story, if it's not the Anunnaki.
I think it's pretty consistent with the Anunnaki story, but I'm, I can't put those words in their heads, right?
Like, I, I don't think that came out in the data, but I think that it's probably the same.
Um, yeah, but I'll just add, you wouldn't, you wouldn't expect it to, um, you would expect some, an idea like that to come out during the analysis phase.
And it is, it, it's absolutely fair to draw, um, parallels between what we're talking about and, and the, at least the basic Anunnaki story.
So yeah, you're not, you're not really too far off at all with that, I wouldn't say.
Yeah.
So we don't know exactly, but it does seem awfully similar to the story.
And when I work with Morgan and Intuitive Underground, right, they, they bring session data to the table.
And I bring a lot of other information and, you know, some of that information is just a pretty good grasp of history, uh, particularly esoteric history, which is a very unusual branch of history that is difficult to, to learn a lot about unless you spend a lot of time just trying to find the information.
Um, so I do think it's the same story, to be honest at the very end of that story.
Um, at the very end of that tinkering, that's when we get stuck in the, uh, in the reality overlay, it seems, it appears.
Um, so some of the changes that are made to human beings are made outside of the reality overlay.
And some of them are made inside or show up inside of the reality overlay.
I know that like the overpopulation issue is connected to human nature.
And it's also, I believe, connected to the session work as something that, um, the archons orchestrated, um, which would mean that they were orchestrating, um, they're orchestrating these changes both outside and inside the reality overlay.
Um, people don't think the same way that we used to, this is important for understanding the paranormal, particularly from the perspective of history.
Um, the way that our brains work, even within the reality overlay has changed.
So if last objective or, or, or subjective, I should say subjective 2,500 years, 3,000 years, um, an excellent book on that.
If anyone is, is looking for material, I assume that the, the, the, the more experienced people here are familiar with all these books.
I, I don't think everyone is.
That's why I'm, but I'm not trying to patronize people if they're like, oh, I, of course we know about that.
What do you, don't be an asshole.
I'm not trying to be patronizing.
I just don't know what people know.
Right.
Um, so the breakdown of the biomacurial mind by, um, by Camarial, I always do that.
The breakdown of the bi-camarial mind by Julian Jaynes.
Genesian, Genesianism.
As you can tell, I'm not very articulate sometimes.
Um, that is a flaw of mine.
Um, and Julian Jaynes talks about looking at how people thought through art and how they express themselves and conspicuously absent forms of self-expression in ancient art.
Uh, particularly the, the concept of the individual, um, introspection, um, internal monologues.
Um, and the, the fact that people seem to record having firsthand experiences of non-human intelligence.
Uh, gods in that case, uh, fairly routinely in ancient fiction.
Um, and Julian, um, went on the assumption that it wasn't a literary device, that it was an honest accounting of the experiences people were having.
A lot of people get involved in studying the UFO phenomenon will then say, well, they were obviously talking to physically present non-human intelligence.
Um, and what Julian Jaynes would say is the way the hemispheres of our brain communicate has changed over time.
And that in the past, um, human, when one hemisphere of the brain communicated to the other, particularly the right hemisphere communicated to the left.
And I know that a lot of that material, uh, from the nineties about the two hemispheres was an inaccurate material.
Uh, but what Jane said was, um, that basically people used to hallucinate quite a bit.
Um, and the daily hallucination was part of the way their, their mind worked, the way their thinking worked.
So we all have heard of people who have had experiences where they're like, they're about to get in a car crash and they hear their dead grandpa say, you know, hey, Bob, and no offense, Bob.
Um, I just picked him in, hey, Bill, Bill, stop, you know, don't go through the red light or whatever.
Um, and we would recognize that as an auditory hallucination, although it could be real, it could really be their grandparent, right?
Julian would say it was their unconscious or their, the right hemisphere of their mind or some aspect of their brain communicating to them through the channel that people used to experience all the time.
So it would not be unusual from his perspective for somebody 3000 years ago to hear God telling him what to do on a, on a fairly routine basis.
Now we, today, if someone experiences that, we call it schizophrenia.
So the basic premise was that human beings used to be, you know, generally have experiences that schizophrenics have today.
Although I want to point out having auditory hallucinations does not make you a schizophrenic.
Almost every human being records reports having some auditory hallucinations during the lifetime.
So if you've had auditory hallucinations, that does not mean you're schizophrenic at all.
If you're having consistent, constant auditory hallucinations, um, that fill you with terror and fear, you should probably see a psychiatrist.
Uh, however, if, you know, you heard your grandpa, Bill, you know, say something at one point in time, when you're walking down the street, that's, that's not something you should worry about.
Um, yeah.
So we, we, we, we talk about this, like with Morgan in our sessions, like, you know, uh, the Greeks didn't have the color blue, you know, and then they developed it over time.
The Egyptians did have the color blue, right?
Like just the way people's brains work changes.
Um, it wasn't, was it Howard Bloom?
I think he made the argument that we didn't really begin to think like modern human beings until Shakespeare.
And he gave a very, like the book, Shakespeare and the invention of the human.
Oh, it's like 5,000 pages.
You probably don't want to read it.
Right.
But it's just exhaustive.
And I think he's, he's got a good point that the, at least the modern way that our minds work as of today showed up then around the time of Shakespeare, right?
It probably, he would say Shakespeare invented that way of thinking.
I mean, I think we could assume that, you know, that was what just sort of emerged out of the unconscious at that time.
And Shakespeare was the, you know, the herald of the, of the new age of thinking.
Um, so when, when people's brains started to change, right?
Um, I'm trying to think of how to say this exactly.
There were two things that we're going to say that like make people uncomfortable.
And the first one is we're going to talk about just briefly about the work of a man named E.O. Wilson.
He was an entomologist, um, just an amazing, amazing individual and a real, um, inspiration to me throughout my life.
Um, uh, he wrote a book called The Social Conquest of the World.
And if you've ever heard of sociobiology, that was E.O. Wilson who created sociobiology.
It's something that should be taught in every school, but it makes people uncomfortable.
And the reason it makes people uncomfortable is, um, you know, E.O.
Um, and I, I don't really remember his, his first name.
I should, um, he, uh, Wilson said, um, you've got these, he broke down different types of socialization based on raising of young.
Um, the one before human beings is pro-social, which is like wolves and lions.
Wolves and lions are pro-social.
They cooperate together to hunt and they cooperate to raise young.
They live in, you know, packs, as you know, or prides.
And people often, um, often make statements.
Like you'll hear in your life, you hear people make a statement like, well, lions behave this way.
Why do human beings behave differently than a lion does or a wolf does?
It's sort of an intuitive sense among people that at one point in time, human beings were pro-social.
And I think that the record shows that like hominids were pro-social, um, in my opinion.
However, human beings, what we have today and what we've emerged from through the reality overlay.
And prior to that, through the tinkering of the archons, we're not pro-social anymore.
We're something different.
And so when we, we try to explain human nature by likening it to a group of wolves, a group of, uh, lions, a group of apes, even, it doesn't work, right?
They didn't have cities.
They didn't fight wars.
They didn't design weapons of mass destruction.
They didn't, you know, didn't farm.
They didn't take slaves.
There are some things that human beings have done that people think only human beings have done, but it's not true.
It's actually true that any eusocial creature has done all of those things.
And so the best example, because EO was an entomologist, he studied ants, right?
The best example is ants.
Ants build cities.
Ants practice agriculture.
Ants build weapons of mass destruction.
Ants take slaves.
Ants have professions.
They have roles, castes, right?
And, and jobs.
Um, they're not generalists like animals are, even pro-social animals.
Um, and what's interesting about that is, I mean, it's interesting to me.
When you talk about human beings and how we've changed through what we perceive as history, people are going to tell you, particularly people in the UFO community, they're going to say, you know, they're going to know this.
They're going to know human brains have shrunk.
They're going to say, look, human brains are significantly smaller than they once were.
The figure often thrown about is 11%.
I don't know if that's accurate.
Um, I have never studied the size of the skulls personally.
I only know what I've read.
But that is what people will tell you, that we've lost about 11% of our gray matter.
And because people don't go back and forth between disciplines, they don't understand how that happened.
And it, we do, people should know how it happened because there is an explanation of exactly how it happens.
And what's interesting about that is the same thing happens in eusocial insects.
So, we think of ants living in giant colonies, but they didn't always live in giant colonies, and many types of ants do not.
As a matter of fact, we have varieties of ants and bees that once lived in giant colonies and have returned to living in a prosocial structure.
Like smaller groups, right?
And so, you can actually see, you can study ants before they become super complicated, when they become super complicated, and when they say, screw it, this isn't the life for us, we're going back.
And what you find is, and this is going to sound familiar to anyone who studied the UFO phenomenon from the perspective of, like, ancient aliens and changes in human beings, right?
The insects all start off a lot larger.
And they start off with much larger brains.
And in the process of becoming eusocial, in the process of becoming collective organisms, which is what a eusocial organism is, it is a species where a significant amount or percentage, I guess, we could say, of the biological imperative of the individual is distributed in the group, as well as the intelligence of the individual is distributed through the group.
So, you know, they work together, they have jobs, they hunt together, most important, they raise young collectively, which is something that goes completely against the biological imperative of any other type of creature, animal, whatever.
So, when a non-eusocial insect, or there are mammals, right, there are the naked mole rats in Africa, there are eusocial mammals.
There are shrimp that are eusocial, that live in colonies, but mostly it's insects.
And this is why people don't talk about it.
The majority of people in the world of, like, biology, et cetera, like, what they'll say, or at least what they write is,
they don't like to think of human beings as insects.
They don't like to use the metaphor, right, because we're not insects.
They don't like to use the metaphor of human beings being, or analogy of human beings like insects in any way.
And they feel that the term eusocial is a metaphor for likening human beings to insects, right, or not likening, you know, as a metaphor.
So, that's why it's not present in a lot of, in a lot of science.
And there's also, for whatever reason, the really, the far left determined immediately that they thought it was a racist idea.
It's not, it shouldn't be a racist idea, but, in anyone's minds, but they determined it was.
And so, they opposed this poor guy, this, like, little ant-studying dude, was just tormented by leftists his entire life, calling him a racist for coming up with this theory.
And it's just true, right?
He was the first person to write it from a scientific perspective.
People in the past knew.
That's why, in the ancient world, they used the beehive as the symbol of human beings.
They know, well, people will tell you, well, it comes from masonry.
Yeah, it comes through masonry, from the ancient world, where they recognized the truth of what, of how human beings had changed.
And that's why, you know, the Mormons use it to this day, right?
They got it from masonry.
Masonry got it from, you know, wherever they got it from.
And those people got it from ancient Mesopotamia.
It's just an acknowledgment of human beings existing as a collective organism.
And, yeah, this guy was just, it really gave this guy a hard time.
And that's why we don't teach people in high schools that human beings are eusocial, when we should.
Because we are, right?
We build cities.
We use agriculture.
Unfortunately, it takes slaves.
You could argue in our society we're all slaves, but that's a different story entirely.
You have classes.
You have jobs and professions, warfare, weapons of mass destruction.
But particularly, we definitely don't have brood queens laying all the eggs, right?
But children are raised collectively in our society, more so all the time.
When I was young, right, that was the beginning of daycare, really.
That was unusual at that time.
And it hasn't been unusual ever since.
But certainly, everyone was rounded up around the age of seven.
And from seven to 18, right, everyone was raised collectively.
So we're not eusocial insects.
We're eusocial mammals.
And that explains the difference between, you know, who has the children.
However, I will point out that the, the, um, techno, uh, the Silicon Valley people, right?
They, um, they want to do that with, they want to do, they want to raise human beings in, like, artificial wombs, right?
There's every couple of years they announce, there's, like, a huge, um, announcement that, uh, they're one step closer to being able to conceive and gestate children in artificial wombs.
That's, uh, human beings moving closer towards being fully eusocial.
And when you get to the point that we're at, where we are, eusocial beings, um, a lot of our, uh, decision-making is, uh, distributed.
A lot of our intelligence is distributed.
And we can see that physically in our lifetime in, like, libraries and universities, right?
But the web was like the quantum leap.
Because now, um, it, it's a lot closer to the, um, whatever method nature uses in other eusocial life forms to distribute information.
Um, uh, chemically, I think, in ants, but I'm not an expert.
And I, you know, I'd just be talking out of my A if I was to start to opine about how ants distribute intelligence chemically.
Um, but they do use some system like that.
And, and human beings do as well.
So when you get into the things that we know about average human beings, decision-making process, um, memes, um, mind viruses, uh, when we talk about the fact that 80% of them, you know,
the Milgram study, 80% of human beings will torture someone to death if told to do so rather than disobey authority.
Like all of that, those disparate pieces of information don't necessarily make sense if you think human beings are apes, the same as a, as a chimpanzee.
But they do if you recognize that human beings are eusocial.
Um, a lot of us are not fully eusocial.
So about 25% of the population is not fully eusocial.
Uh, we're still in a transition period.
Um, or we are the individuals from outside the reality of like, that's, that's a different discussion.
Um, those of us who are not fully eusocial, um, those of us who are not fully part of the collective mind, right?
All have the same experiences in life.
We all have the same experiences of thinking the people around us kind of crazy.
We all have the same experiences of seeing people just absorb cultural memes and manners of speaking ideas and opinions almost overnight.
And it makes no sense to us because there was no logical, reasonable argument involved.
There was no, you know, progression in people's understanding.
It was just, they woke up one day and it's like, they've been reprogrammed.
Um, not in a paranoid sense, just in a, in a cultural sense.
Right.
And, uh, that is the, that is eusociality.
And when we talk about this, these technological changes and we say, well, who the fuck would want, who the fuck would want any of this?
Right.
We start hearing about the, um, oh, this might, I might get bumped here, Morgan.
The, um, bio-digital convergence, right?
When we start hearing about that and all the effort that's being put into combined human beings with machines, uh, those of us who are not of that bent, it seems insane to us.
The idea seems insane.
The desire seems insane.
That is the, um, that is the eusociality.
When you hear about environmental toxicity, and I'm, I'm going back to the paranormal, but I'm just trying to explain the big picture.
When you hear about environmental toxicity and the effects of chemicals in the water, in the air, some of which, particularly people in UFOX and, and conspiracy circles believe or put there intentionally.
And they may be.
However, if you accept that human beings are eusocial, you will recognize that the results are the intention.
Just like in a human being, right?
What people habitually, the result that a human being habitually gets is what they actually intend to do.
And the rest is rationalization.
The same thing is true in a collective sense.
So if we keep getting, this is a good example, endocrine disruptors in our water, right?
And we just, how do they get with medicine, endocrine disruptors and rubber from tire is an endocrine disruptor.
Like, wow, geez, we keep finding birth control in the water, and that's an endocrine disruptor.
And, right, we just, endocrine disruptors are falling from the sky, and no one knows how the endocrine disruptors got there.
Well, what do you know about your social creatures, right?
They modify the environment using chemistry.
That's a fact.
The ants, bees, they modify their environment using chemistry to various degrees.
Ants, of course, more than anything else.
Okay, termites.
And it's not something that's a conscious individual decision.
It's a collective act that we have to assume they don't individually understand.
The purpose of that act, in the case of something like an endocrine disruptor, is to create drones, right?
I mean, that's not a controversial statement.
That's just a fact.
So, I think that when we talk about, like, how that stuff is happening and why it's happening, it's part of this collective experience.
Now, with the paranormal, you have people having similar experiences where they don't quite understand what's happening.
They don't quite understand why it's happening.
It just is, right?
And it creates cognitive dissonance, and people have to come up with theories.
Like, well, why, you know, how many theories are there of why people are having alien abductions and encounters and experiences?
And why the phenomenon is here, and, you know, what it intends and what it will do in the future.
That is an intrusion, right?
That is a collective cognitive dissonance trying to explain an intrusion.
But oftentimes, the intrusion in our lives, that is a result of a collective unconscious.
So, we loop back to Jung, right?
Trying to explain how it would be inside a collective organism, which is what he did.
You have these emerging archetypes.
You have these experiences coming out of a collective unconscious.
And it's the collective communicating with us as opposed to the individual.
And, of course, Jung wrote the book Flying Saucers, right?
So, that is how he explained it.
And that's how Terence McKenna looked at it.
These encounters with the paranormal were communications from the collective to the individual.
And the reason that's possible, the reason that makes sense, that the paranormal is a communication from the collective to the individual, is because human beings are eusocial.
That's why I went on a long rant about human beings and ants.
I know it sounds like a digression, but it's not.
That's why it happened, right?
And that's why we can sort of rest assured that the collective messages of archetypes and synchronicities, right, are important, but not necessarily true and accurate.
It's not necessarily what it purports to be.
I don't even know if there's necessarily an identity to the phenomenon itself.
It's just an overlay, just like the reality overlay.
It's just an overlay that results.
Obviously, I'm not saying ants see UFOs, but if they did, they would respond the same way human beings do.
Morgan, I assume that you don't have any data on human eusociality.
You there, buddy?
Not directly, not as such, but what you're talking about, I think, is in line with our bigger picture, sure.
Right.
So, the way it happens, this is the other thing that's, like, controversial.
The way it happens is through the domestication process.
Biologists don't study.
They don't tend to study.
The same biologists don't tend to study wild animals and domesticated animals.
So, it's very hard to find good information on domestication.
The only reason we really know anything about domestication is there was a project in the Soviet Union, the Soviet Union fox project, where they took a bunch of fur foxes and turned them into domestic dogs, basically.
Or domestic foxes, really, right?
But they're very close to dogs.
And they did it, inadvertently, they did it because they were tired of being attacked by the foxes.
So, they started breeding the less dominant animals.
This is a trigger, again, for people.
So, don't listen if you're going to get triggered by this idea.
So, what happens is when you breed the less dominant foxes, there is a feedback loop.
Feedback loop.
I usually have a beer.
That's why I'm less articulate this time.
I usually have a beer when I'm talking.
But I'm not having one today.
So, there is that feedback loop between melanin and adrenaline.
And when you breed for animals who produce less adrenaline, you experience consistent morphological changes in the animal.
And what they found when they did this with foxes over the course of 20 or so generations, they found that the foxes' ears became droopy.
The tail became droopy.
The foxes started to bark, as opposed to the sounds they were making prior to that.
And the coats changed.
They were no longer gray foxes that began to develop all manner of spots and coloration, much like dogs and cats have.
This is a trigger, but human beings as well, right?
So, if you look at how human beings have changed since we emerged from our original, right, our original hominid form, you'll hear a lot of people explain, well, you'll hear the evolutionary explanations in school.
I think they probably stopped teaching those.
But they taught us that when they were young.
I'm going to tell you right now, another trigger warning.
When I was young, they used to teach us that the reason Asians looked Asian was because they used to work in rice fields.
And they had evolved so that rain would run off their faces.
I wish I could tell you that wasn't true, that I was making that up.
But that is what they taught me when I was in ninth grade.
It shows you how much the world changes in 30 years.
So, in UFO circles, you'll hear people say, well, it could be related to interaction with different forms of non-human intelligence.
It could.
There's also, right, different hominid intermixture.
You have Denisovans in East Asia and Southeast Asia, where you don't have it in Europe, where you have Neanderthal and you don't have Neanderthal or Denisovan in South Saharan Africa, right?
So, there's a genetic basis for it.
However, a lot of the changes in human beings are the same as changes in every other domestic animal.
We've lost hair.
That's another thing.
Dwarfism and giganticism are traits that you find in domesticated creatures and in hybrids.
That's another story.
The changes in the amount of hair, losing hair, the changes in skin coloration, the floppiness of the ears.
You know, a lot of us have floppy ears, but some of us have seen people who have, like, the fixed original ear, right?
So, that was the original ear.
Our floppy ears are part of what was a domestication process.
Changes in our bone density.
Things that are ascribed to genetic interference by extraterrestrials.
And the UFO circles are actually generally consistent with the domestication process.
That is a genetic change.
So, that's not saying there wasn't a genetic change.
There was a genetic change.
However, it's consistent with the process of domestication, right?
As opposed to, like, something that someone just invented randomly by randomly gene splicing or whatever.
Now, this is controversial.
And this, I cannot back up.
This, I cannot back up.
This was something that I encountered in the 1990s.
No one, I cannot find anyone who studies the genetics of domesticated animals.
However, it has been suggested that the fused chromosome that human beings have is common in domesticated animals.
And it's a byproduct of the domestication process and not a random event or the result of genetic engineering.
I believe that's most likely true.
But I cannot find anyone who's an expert in cat genetics or dog genetics to talk to me about it.
So, I can't say it with authority, but I do tend to believe that that's the case.
In the big, the kicker, the domestication process results in the shrinking of the brain.
So, the process of becoming a collective organism, eusocial, results in 11% decline in cranial volume, brain volume.
And human beings have, of course, approximately 11% less cranial brain volume than a Cro-Magnon or a Neanderthal, right?
So, if you take the domestication process that we saw in the Soviet fox experiment, they sell those foxes today.
People in the United States of America buy those foxes from the Russians as pets.
They're still around.
If you take that data from that project and extrapolate from it, then the changes in human beings in the last 50,000 years are pretty much consistent with, first, hominid admixture, right?
The interbreeding with Neanderthals and Denisovans and God knows what other hominids, okay?
We don't know.
There are suggestions, apparently, that there are other ghost hominids involved.
And then domestication.
And so, while I don't doubt for a second that the Anunnaki could be from Nibiru, it is also quite possible that the Anunnaki and other forms of what we call non-human intelligence today are other forms of hominids from the Earth.
And, again, I'm not a guy who's completely against it.
Like, they could be from Mars.
Like, they could very well be aliens from Mars.
They could be from Mars.
They could be from Nibiru.
I'm not arguing against it.
What I'm saying is that a lot of what we understand, what we group together with that concept, Nephilim and Anunnaki and giants, is explainable through the process that I'm outlining right now.
Very explainable, you know, this is going to sound, this is going to be the craziest digression of this whole thing, right?
I'm sure everyone here is familiar with the Liger, L-I-G-E-R from Napoleon Dynamite.
The younger people may never have seen that movie.
The older people will have seen that movie.
But I think everyone is familiar with the concept of a Liger across being a lion and a tiger.
And they're pretty huge.
And they're pretty healthy.
And they're also pretty calm, right?
So the reason that they have those traits is the same reason why we have big old apples and oranges.
It's called hybrid vigor, right?
And so two things about hybridization, which is also something that the biologists who study, right, one don't study the other.
So biologists study wild animals.
Some biologists, very few of them study domestication.
And some biologists study hybrids.
Very, very few of them.
And none of them talk to each other.
However, hybridization is something that happens in nature.
It's observable.
It's not true that hybrids can't reproduce.
A lot of hybrids can't reproduce.
However, a lot can.
And you do find those, the traces of that in the genetics of wild animals.
The process of creating these hybrids generally creates very large, robust versions of the animal.
So the same way that a liger is twice as large or three times as large as a lion or a tiger, because it is the cross between a lion and a tiger.
It is certainly explainable.
It would be predictable that a cross between a human being and a Neanderthal would experience hybrid vigor.
They wouldn't all be huge, but they would be huge, and particularly once the process of domestication was underway, that's when dwarfism and gigantism are part of the process.
Because all domesticated animals have dwarfs and little versions of themselves and larger versions.
And when we look at the history of human interaction with NHI, we see they don't just talk about giants, they also talk about tiny little guys.
The tiny little guys often get written out, but the tiny little guys played a bigger role than the Morgan.
Someone's requesting, and that's cool if they come up, but I got to finish this rant before we have all the, right, before we have the questions.
Yeah, now I am not co-host, so I'm not able to...
Oh, you're not co-host, shit!
That's right.
Fuck, I'm going to get bumped, and this is going to crash.
I'll try to send you co-host again.
Hey, Ailey, I'm going to bring you up, dude, but I'm going to keep rambling on.
And Morgan, let me, before I, can you, let me try to send you co-host again.
Yeah, go ahead, but I mean, that's, I'm not even seeing the...
I know.
Hey, Joseph, I'm going to send you a co-host invitation, maybe it'll go through to you.
Um, just to have someone up there so that when I crash because I say something fucking stupid that I'm not supposed to say, this won't be the end.
So those traits are explainable through regular biological processes is the important thing.
That's not necessarily paranormal.
Giants and dwarves in history are not necessarily paranormal.
They're very possibly biological and explainable through the beginning, way back in the beginning,
uh, when Neanderthal man and, um, and the ancestors of human beings met, well, there are ancestors too, right?
Uh, met, and they met in the Levant, by the way.
They met in, um, the area around Syria, the Golan Heights.
And as far as we can tell, right?
Mount Hermon, like that, you know, where the fallen angels were supposed to be.
Well, that happened to be that the top of Mount Hermon, you find Neanderthal settlements,
and in the bottom, we find human settlements going back a certain period of time.
Um, those are changes.
So it seems as if what might have occurred is, uh, during the period where human, um, where hominids were meeting,
all these primitive human beings were meeting and they were mingling and they began to have hybrids.
And some of those hybrids had the hybrid vigor and they were very smart.
They were like Gilgamesh, right?
They were very smart and they were very big and very strong.
And they took over and those very well could be the Anunnaki.
And if that happened, what they did was, uh, they started societies, they started cities.
And as part of that, and this is an unpleasant thing to think about, they had a breeding program
because they determined who was and wasn't allowed to marry whom.
And in that situation where you've got these like very strong leaders, right?
Um, people who maybe wouldn't have had the same reproductive access, uh, out as a hunter gatherer,
but might be an excellent scribe, say, um, maybe gifted again, uncomfortable, but true.
Maybe gifted a wife or two wives or who knows how many wives in that situation.
And what you have there is, um, a breeding program that is going to reinforce breeding the less dominant men.
And you're going to experience the process of domestication, even without putting someone in a cell
and splicing their genes, which we do believe happened.
Um, so I, I believe this is all together the same, the same phenomenon.
People were hallucinating back then, apparently.
And they were also seeing very strange things, um, in, in waking reality, aside from hallucinations.
It's very possible that a lot of what we experience is the paranormal is, it traces back to that moment.
And it could be people communicate.
It could be us communicating ourselves.
It could be the collective unconscious communicating to us.
It could be non-human intelligence communicating to us or manipulating us or preying on us from beyond the reality overlay.
Um, and it could also be an artifact of the fact that human beings are a collective organism or a series of collective organisms, um, experiencing individual and collective hallucinations, which is, is also accurate.
As real as real as aliens are, as real as real as aliens are, as real as aliens are, human beings being collective organisms experiencing individual and collective hallucinations is just as real, if not more real.
And once you understand that it, it makes sense of a lot of the NHI phenomenon that isn't explained by physical, um, uh, physical trophies, physical, um, waste or, um, wreckage or whatever they're finding.
Right.
I mean, I, I, I don't know how many intact vessels they find, but they supposedly find crashed vessels, right?
So I guess trash waste, whatever.
Um, yeah, so that, that's, that is the nature of human beings that people don't talk about.
Human beings are both domesticated and that's a fact, um, that you'll find in certain quarters of biology, but people won't talk about because it makes people uncomfortable.
Very uncomfortable, particularly people who are kind of woke and left, and that's not to criticize the woke left.
I'm just saying it makes them very uncomfortable to think about that.
Um, but we, we, we know that because of the Soviet Fox domestication program, we know exactly how it happened.
We know exactly what to look for, uh, to see that it happened.
And it clearly happened with human beings.
Human beings are hybridized.
We know that's true.
Um, and we can, um, we know what to look for and the genes are there.
We know what hybrid vigor looks like.
Another interesting part of the, the way people appear and how it varies from geographical area to geographical area and how that relates to the genetics of the hybridization with other hominids as opposed to extraterrestrials is, um, hybrid
hybrid introgression, which what that means is that when there's a hybrid organism, it is more likely to resemble the genetic line that contributes the least DNA rather than the most DNA.
So if you hybridize two, two lines, two types of animal or two types of fruit or whatever, um, the type that contributes 20% of the DNA is, is going to generally be what the, um,
what the final version looks like in the end, somewhere down the line, uh, someone else is requesting.
Okay.
But still no co-host so that when I crash, um, my crashes is all gone.
Um, so that's where paranormal and human nature are combined.
The paranormal as communication between us outside the reality overlay and also communication between the collective and the individual,
which is where young was coming from, which was where Terrence McKenna was coming from.
And it's something I think that people don't think about as much now.
Um, because we like, we like the cool stories, right?
And they're cool up to a point.
They're cool up to a point.
And I think in my personal opinion, when you get to the point where you're, you're in, um,
Charles McNeil land and you know, you're, you're talking about with, with great authority about,
um, all manner of extraterrestrials and saying that human beings have been to their home planets.
I think we're stretching it there.
I could be wrong.
Um, but I think that in most cases, it's much more likely that what we experience is,
as paranormal and even extraterrestrial is, is a part of our collective conscious or our collective unconscious,
um, welling up into the collective conscious in the form of, uh, I mean, hallucination is, uh,
again, we believe people live in a reality over there.
So when we say it's hallucination, we're not saying that in a way to like demean anyone.
We're not saying that like, Oh, you're crazy or hallucinating because in a sense, all of
this is a hallucination and we experienced it as very real.
So anything up to as real as what we experienced from our perspective is, is hallucination.
Um, I got a couple of people on deck who want to say something.
So we're going to, um, we're going to pull them in and, and, uh, see what they have to say.
Uh, alien, you were first alien PR.
Thank you so much.
Last for this thoughtful space and your, um, you know, innovative insights.
And my, just like hearing how you think.
And, you know, I, I think we oftentimes lose touch with the fact that modern humans have
been around for 300,000 years, 300,000 years through, I think it's five glaciations.
And, you know, I think seven interglacial periods and up until I guess, you know, 12, 15,000 years
ago, um, you know, we seem to believe that we didn't have civilization before that.
We didn't have advancement before that.
We didn't have the, uh, the human nature that we have now.
And that's so not true.
And you can imagine what it could have been like with the megafauna before the
Adams event 42,000 years ago, um, where we were surrounded by Neanderthals, Devisonians,
um, you know, uh, homo Florensis and all the different, you know, um, relatives and the
implications of our genetic history and, um, things that we don't even consider too much.
Things like genetic memory.
Animals do repeat behaviors that they've never seen before because of what must be a
genetic memory of some kind, very specific mating behaviors, nesting behaviors that are extremely
detailed and fascinating behaviors.
But you see that in the animal kingdom and how much more so are we influenced by our genetic
past and genetic influences.
So I just appreciate this conversation and thank you for having me.
Thank you for saying so.
Uh, Jay Justy or sorry, it's just Justy.
For some reason, I thought there were two Jays.
I apologize.
There used to be.
So, um, I have a question.
You said that human beings were hybridized.
Um, what's the proof of that?
I'm just not that I don't believe that.
I kind of do believe that, but I just want to know what the proof is scientifically of that.
Okay.
So the, here's the thing, right?
Like there was this expectation in the, in the UFO circles for years that, you know, human
beings were part of this hybridization program or had been hybridized with ancient aliens.
Now the intuitive underground remote viewing work would tend to indicate that something like
that did occur.
That's not what I'm saying.
Um, I'm not ruling it out.
What I'm pointing out is that what came of that expectation was around 2006, they admitted that
human beings were hybridized, uh, were hybrid animals.
Um, it's one of the reasons, it was a science.
You can Google it.
Yeah.
It's the, the scientific community on planet earth admits that human beings are hybridized.
Um, Europeans are, have about between two and 6% Neanderthal DNA, depending on the individual.
Uh, East Asians have, uh, two to 4% Neanderthal DNA and between two to 6% Denisovan DNA.
And we didn't really know what Denisovans look like until about a month ago.
We knew that existed because they found finger bones in Siberia and they got the genetics from
the finger bones and they were able to match it to genetics of people of East Asian origin.
Um, however, they didn't have a complete body.
And then about a month ago, a story emerged from China called dragon man about a man, about,
um, a species of hominid with very large heads, very physically robust.
What we would consider to be not giants, but gigantic.
Think like Andre, the giant size, right?
Um, and when they did a genetic sequence on that, they did discover that that was in fact,
uh, Denisovans, so, um, and when they look at the DNA of subfix, excuse me, sub Saharan Africans,
uh, what they find is that there are clear indications of one or more ghost lineages,
one or more, um, uh, phantom hominids.
And that I'm not a geneticist, so I can't make the argument that what they're saying is true,
but they do accept it as true.
It is scientifically accepted that homo sapiens, um, in sub Saharan Africa encountered and hybridized
with other hominids in antiquity, like far, far distant past.
But it was around 50 to 30,000 years ago that the Neanderthal and Denisovan genetic introgression
happened.
And that's around when, um, that's around when, uh, Cro-Magnon man appeared.
It is true what, um, what alien PR was saying that human beings have been around for,
according to science, 300,000 years.
However, about 50,000 years ago, between 50,000 and 11,000 years ago, it was a significant
series of biological changes in human beings.
Um, we used to have like much thicker, heavier bones, and, um, we used to have larger brains
and we've gotten smaller and our brains have gotten smaller and our bones have gotten more
porous.
And, um, that was the series of events that occurred after hybridization.
What I was pointing out is that when you study hybridization, um, hybrid vigor is a concept
that is used to explain why hybrids tend to be larger, healthier, and smarter than whatever
their original lineage, their parents' lineages were, their parents' species were, right?
So when we look at what the ancient stories tell us of these gigantic people popping up who were
smarter than everyone else and brought civilization to human beings, you know, and at that time they
weren't talking about computers, they were talking about like metallurgy, things like that.
So, you know, at some point in the distant past, you know, more than 5,000 years ago, a bunch of giants
popped up and they were smart and they were working with metals and they were practicing agriculture
or beginning to practice at practice agriculture and they gave it to the people who served them, which were the other people.
That's the other thing about that is that the, everyone else was very quickly turned into servants of those beings.
One way to explain that is to say something extraterrestrial happened, but hybrid vigor, a, a known, um,
scientific principle involving hybridization also explains that process.
So who, what could have hybrided, like what, what, from this perspective, okay, so this would have been, this is not the, not the hybridizing together.
This is not the aliens, right?
This is because that, that very well could have happened.
I'm not arguing against that.
This is hominid hybridization.
So hominids had distant ancestors millions of years ago.
They split up and they were separated for hundreds of thousands of years, right?
Neanderthals and Homo sapiens were separated for about 500,000 years.
So they were different species at that time.
Like we might see them as human beings.
Now we might put Denisovans, uh, homeless Heidelbergus, um, homeless erectus, uh, ancient Homo sapiens.
We might rope them all up in a room and say like, well, some people are kind of what we imagined to be primitive, but they all look like human beings.
We don't know because we haven't seen them.
Right.
But we assume based on the skeletons that that's true, but they were different species.
And so when Homo sapiens came out of Africa, it encountered Neanderthal man in the Levant, right?
In, in the Middle East.
And there were, there was interbreeding between Homo sapiens and Neanderthals.
And when Homo sapiens made it to East Asia, they encountered Denisovan man.
And there was interbreeding between Homo sapiens and Denisovan man.
Now those two species of hominids have disappeared, but we still carry their genes to this day.
And you're familiar with some of that genetic legacy, like, uh, cystic fibrosis.
Cystic fibrosis is caused by Neanderthal genes.
Um, Neanderthals had very hardy immune systems.
And so, uh, after the interbreeding, um, evolution or natural selection tended to conserve Neanderthal immune system genes.
So when we find like the genes that modern Europeans have from Neanderthals, most of them involve the immune system.
So that's, that's hybridization.
It's what hybridization actually means, right?
So there's like, it could be alien hybridization, but like every apple, every orange, every banana that you, that you consume as a hybrid.
Right.
And like the, we talked about that funny, the liger from Napoleon dynamite, right?
The liger is a hybrid.
So there are hybrids around us right now.
And if you go out and sample a certain amount of birds and, and things in, in the, in the jungle, right?
You, you do find natural hybrids out there.
It's, it's strange, but different species do reproduce.
Usually it leads to sterility.
Usually it leads to those species disappearing, but not always.
It didn't in the case of human beings.
Another trait that we talk about, like,
why are human beings like we're not very fertile, right?
And even before all of this modern stuff that lowered human fertility, human beings weren't very fertile.
And as a woman, you know, that in the past women used to die in childbirth quite a bit, which is not common in the animal world.
And so people in the UFO community, some of them back in the nineties, used to ascribe that to the possibility of ancient nuclear war causing genetic mutations.
That may be true, but it wasn't accurate.
It wasn't completely accurate because it, it turns out that these problems, for instance, the problem that women have bringing children to term, you know, are thought now to result from that hybridization process.
As well as like the low human fertility, it may seem like human beings are really fertile or were like in our grandparents' age, but not like animals.
Go ahead.
You have a, you have more questions?
You want me to ask?
Well, you can Google it.
I mean, if you don't believe me, just Google it.
Neanderthal DNA.
No, I believe it.
I'm not, I'm not questioning you.
No, no, no.
I'm just questioning.
Yeah, of course.
So would you say that Neanderthal genes, they're hyper, they have hyper immune systems?
I'm curious.
It seemed that they had, they had very robust immune systems and that those immune systems were adapted for the cold climate in Northern Europe.
And it was something human beings needed.
There's a, I believe that nature is very intelligent.
I, I don't think we, we, we use terms like natural selection and we kind of dismiss it because it's distributed.
It's networked.
And until we developed computer technology, we didn't really have a way of understanding networked intelligence.
And so we didn't see it anywhere.
But since we developed computer technology, particularly the internet, it gives us a metaphor to understand cognitively, to understand networked intelligence and how the sum of a number of connected things can be intelligent in a way the individual isn't.
And a good example of this is like trees, trees and mushrooms.
Like, you know, when I was young, when I was young, like the idea that the trees and, and, and, and vegetables and mushrooms had any intelligence at all was completely bonkers, batshit crazy.
But now it's something scientists write about, they write about it fairly frequently, that because of the mycelial connections, the connections from the little fibers in the roots of different trees and mushrooms and, and other plant life, there seems to be some sort of larger intelligence generated.
That can predict where trees grow, sometimes when a tree dies, other trees will keep that tree alive, like what's left of it, just the trunk without any, without any greenery.
They'll keep it alive, sometimes they won't, there are a tremendous number of decisions that are made, and we have to assume that they're made in a distributed manner, as opposed to being decisions made by an individual tree, which I think we would all say we couldn't really understand how that might work.
How the distributed intelligence works, I don't know, personally, but I know that that's, that's what we find everywhere we look now.
I can say like, if there's a mechanism for it, like, there's a great book called, very, very good book, particularly if you have Gnostic leanings, from the 1990s, called The Cosmic Gene.
I, I can't recommend that book enough, and one of the things that we, we talk about now, like, especially people who are like love and lighters, but people in the community will talk about bio photons, the light that human cells emit, and it's actually admitted by human DNA, but it's admitted by all DNA, and so it turns out that life and living things emit light.
It's one of the reasons that dead people look weird to us, is that after a certain period of being dead, dead people no longer emit light.
We all emit light, the trees emit light, the animals emit light, and what the author of The Cosmic Gene, who I believe his last name is Darby, but it's been a long time, what he talked about was, using the metaphor of early distributed intelligence, the internet, he hypothesized that the communication is the light.
That cells communicate, that cells communicate with each other, both internally, and with external organisms, through the emission and reception of bio photons.
If that's true, that would explain things like Qigong, and Tai Chi, and, and Chi, and Prana, and a number of ideas that people have.
I don't know if I've, if I've gone astray from your original question, I thought it was about distributed intelligence, but I may have just gone off on a tangent and completely forgot what I was talking about.
It's okay, it's interesting.
I've experienced cell memory myself, so I believe in that, and are you saying that like, that it's the body, basically, it's, it's like the cells working together, and they create a light, like, almost like a chemical reaction, is that what you're saying?
I, I would be, if I, if I gave you an authoritative answer to that, I'd be lying, because I, I don't, I'm, I'm like a journalist.
I'm not, I'm not an expert in bio photons.
I know they're real, and they're something that is, is well acknowledged now.
It wasn't in the 90s.
It was just starting to be acknowledged at that time.
So we know that's a real phenomenon, that, that living cells give off light, and that, that light comes from the DNA of the cells, and the form of photons released by the DNA that we call bio photons.
I don't think the cells themselves, it's like something going on in the DNA, but if you ask me, like, what's the physical mechanism for the creation of light, I can't tell you that.
I don't know.
I would be lying.
I'd be confabulating, and that wouldn't, I don't like to spread misinformation.
It's unavoidable to spread a little, but you never want to spread any intentionally, you know?
Okay, thank you.
You're welcome.
Yeah, so I think my original point was that there is, there is an intelligence in nature, and I think that, yeah, that's what I was saying.
I think that the, the distributed intelligence of nature is much smarter than just human beings, right?
Because we're just a part of that, and it's much smarter than what we would imagine when we talk about AI superintelligence.
AI superintelligence will take hold.
Well, there's never going to be an AI superintelligence that's smarter than the distributed intelligence of the entire human race.
It's not possible.
If it were possible, there would definitely not be any possibility that there will ever be an intelligence that's more intelligent than the distributed intelligence of all life.
So we, we think nature is, we'll say, oh, nature is smart, but we're kind of dismissive of it because it's not a centralized intelligence.
When it's not like, we don't go someplace and stand in front of the avatar of nature who talks to us directly, right?
It's not, we don't have a human interaction with it.
So we, we underestimate the intelligence.
But when you talk about things like hybridization, right, we would say, well, it's an accident.
It's a random occurrence.
I don't believe that's true.
I think that when animals hybridize, particularly because they conserve genes around the immune system, oftentimes, and in human beings, that was the case.
I don't think it's a random thing.
I think it's part of the higher intelligence of nature.
When you recognize that nature has a distributed intelligence and that human beings are a collective organism, you can, you can come to the conclusion that while non-human entities could hijack people, right?
Like, they could be non-human hitchhikers and they could hijack individuals, it is probably much more common that nature itself, in a sense, hijacks individuals and directs them to courses of behavior they don't consciously intend to follow.
And the result of that, of those courses of behavior, can be things like hybrids and the conservation of Neanderthal, you know, immune DNA that, to this day, right, um, if you have one copy of the cystic fibrosis gene, you have a much healthier immune system.
It's when you have two copies that you, you develop cystic fibrosis.
That's why that was conserved.
So I think it all serves a larger purpose.
I think that the Victorians would call it a clockwork universe.
That there's an underlying clockwork that really, um, motivates us.
It's almost hijacks us sometimes to do things that are advantageous for the collective organism.
Uh, there's an individual I'm sure you've all heard of.
Uh, he's a very mixed bag and we could do an entire episode on that.
But there's never been any interest.
And since there's never been any interest, it would probably never happen.
His name is Brian Johnson and he's a very important individual.
He is a much more important individual than anyone imagined.
As a matter of fact, like all great and important people, he is generally laughed at.
Which is something all great and important people go through at different periods of life.
I'm not saying he's a good person.
I'm not saying that he's, he's important because he's good.
I'm saying that he is, uh, he's important in a way that most people don't recognize.
And one of the things that he has been talking about for years, and it's correct, he's not the only one, is that all life forms a global immune system.
And that's true.
Um, we have our individual immune systems.
However, when you add our individual immune systems together, life is, um, a large layered immune system.
And I think a lot of the conservation that goes on genetically is related to the immune system.
And what's interesting about that from a paranormal perspective is that a lot of paranormal experiences are related to immune system, immune system, to, um, immunology, uh, both, uh, the abduction experiences, um, the non-human intelligence, the extraterrestrials talk about, um, needing to modify their genome in some way.
Uh, but also historically the actual experiences themselves, right?
Well, William Bramley, what he would tell you is, uh, the two times we would tend to see extraterrestrials are on wars and plagues.
And so we focus on the war aspect of it.
We don't talk about the plague aspect of it.
But in fact, as far as I remember from his book and also other thought available at that time when I was part of the UFO disclosure movement, um, historically the majority of sightings that were recorded.
Seemed to involve, um, plagues and pestilence and, and being cited prior to during and after, uh, those events.
So it would seem that as whether it's actual people getting out of a saucer and interacting, or whether it's a hallucination that's coming out of the collective unconscious.
It is closely tied together with the global immune system.
Morgan, you got anything?
Um, well, yeah, actually, I I'd like to mention just jumping back a couple of minutes there.
Yeah.
Awesome.
What you were talking about with regard to, uh, you know, what did you call it?
The, uh, not, not exactly the collective unconscious, but the, the kind of the master intelligence, the, of nature.
Yeah, exactly.
Um, you know, I'm not sure if you, or, uh, I'm, I'm sure some people here are familiar with the work of, uh, Nassim Harameen.
He's a kind of, uh, kind of, I don't know what you'd call him, a bit, a bit of a renegade, mostly self-taught kind of theoretical physicist type.
Um, now he caught my attention some years ago and I kind of really fell down the rabbit hole with him.
He's very interesting.
He's, um, always, always in pursuit of, um, I think a unified field theory, you know, that, that kind of combines, um,
Well, it bridges physics where, um, you know, certain fields of physics do not necessarily, uh, unite, uh, at present, at least as, as it's currently understood.
But ultimately, uh, the, the point I'm getting at is one of, one of his concepts is, is very much aligned with what you were just talking about there.
And that is that mathematically, logically, the way that he would put it, uh, and I, I think I'm, I'm in full agreement here, is that in order for things, life forms, uh, more complex life forms, and, you know, ultimately very complex life forms.
Um, and systems such as ourselves, in order for them to emerge with such rapidity, there must be some type of an underlying feedback mechanism.
Um, and, if I remember correctly, one of the analogies he gives is, he says, you know, given the presumed, um, length of time that, that the entire universe has existed for.
Something as simple as a Rubik's cube, um, just under random, you know, if, if a Rubik's cube made one random move per second, it would take the entire length of the existence of the universe and it theoretically may still not be solved.
But with a simple yes, no feedback mechanism in place, that time, I, I, again, I can't remember off the top of my head, but that it, it cuts the time down to solving that problem to just a fraction of a fraction of a fraction of, of the amount of time, uh, absent that feedback mechanism.
And I think that's very much in line with, with what you were, you were getting at.
Yeah, absolutely.
And, you know, we're going to leave out the Gothic horror stuff from this space because that's becoming our, our trademark.
Right.
Um, and so I'm not going to touch on it too closely.
Um, however, like that, that feedback mechanism and its presence in life is one of the reasons that, or one of the reasons given why, um, human neurologic or neurological tissue in general, not human.
Could be mouse tissue or, uh, organoids are potentially superior to AI from a computing perspective because AI needs to be trained and you see it as being making very intelligent and making these leaps of understanding.
But in fact, sometimes if it's making a leap of understanding, it's been trained 500,000 times in order to get it to that next leap of understanding or that next level.
Whereas life teaches itself through that series of feedback mechanisms, which I'm not going to lie and say I understand completely because I don't.
Um, and so, you know, the, the organoids, the neurological tissue will, will learn on its own as opposed to needing to be trained.
Um, and that is what the argument is makes it superior.
And I think that that is in life in general, right?
Life in general has a distributed intelligence that allows it to make decisions and learn.
Um, and somehow that intelligence is shared, is networked, that learning is shared network, right?
We call it a hundred monkeys and I don't know how accurate the hundred monkey phenomenon is the story that they told when I was younger about washing the potatoes on the islands that monkeys were taught to wash potatoes.
And that when it got to a hundred monkeys who could wash potatoes, all the monkeys could then wash potatoes.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't, it sounds apocryphal, um, as I've gotten older, it was, it was really awesome when I was a teenager.
Um, and it may be true.
I'm just saying, I don't know if it is true, but I think the, as an anecdote, the, the principle that it, that it explains, that it demonstrates is accurate, right?
I think we all know that, uh, particularly human beings, but it does seem nature also has a way of, of, um, transmitting the, the information learned by organisms to other organisms, probably, you know, at any distance, but that's speculation.
Um, because we don't exactly know how it works.
We just can say that nature itself is, is, is, is vastly more intelligent than anything, anything else.
And, um, from a perspective of the reality overlay to circle back to where we began.
And this is going to be like, I don't think anyone here is going to be particularly shocked by this.
Cause I don't think anyone here has a particular investment in the concepts of, of Gnosticism.
However, going back to the cosmic gene, um, you know, what, what he was able to show very conclusively, um, through using artwork, artwork and, um,
shamanic experience, uh, experiences generated through the use of hallucinogenics in Aboriginal cultures, um, into like modern, um, modern hallucinogenic experiences and artwork.
And he went through a number of different sources, but I think what he demonstrated very conclusively is DNA is the demiurge, which is why it is often depicted as having the body of a snake.
Um, and it is also why people who use, um, hallucinogens like Iocasa, um, tend to hallucinate snakes entwined all over the place.
His hypothesis was that using hallucinogens allowed direct communication between an individual and their DNA or DNA in general.
I don't know if that's true.
It may be.
I, it makes sense.
Um, and I'm not dismissing people's belief in non-physical spirits that are in the mix.
Uh, I'm not, or other levels of reality.
I'm not taking away from anyone else's beliefs.
I'm, I'm just saying there's another level and it's more of a foundational level that we often don't think about or look at.
Um, but when I say that DNA is the demiurge, if you think about this, Morgan and everyone else, but particularly Morgan,
within the reality overlay, DNA is the building block.
It's the Lego or the brain of the Lego, right?
That puts us all together.
We have, we certainly have a physical planet or, I mean, no, it's okay.
We don't, um, but there's a physical planet somewhere, right?
We certainly have, uh, non-biological material that we perceive around us on a day-to-day basis.
However, the sum of the world in our perception, um, is biological, right?
I mean, I don't know about everyone else, but I spend my, most of my time looking in front of me as opposed to down or up.
Um, and so the majority of what I see every day and encounter every day is biological.
And, um, from that perspective, from the biocentrist perspective, which is another, another dude, another book, but also very interesting biocentrism, right?
Uh, the reality overlay itself is biocentric.
It is built around biology as opposed to biology being built around inanimate material.
Um, and so that, that building block, the, um, the distributed networked little brain, and I'm using that as a metaphor.
It's obviously not a brain.
Little driver is the DNA found in, in cells, it seems, um, so the archons are beings from our data.
Um, and they are certainly beings as experienced inside the reality overlay where they were experienced as the gods, uh, and Anunnaki may be outside and inside, but definitely inside as well, right?
And may be experienced as extraterrestrials.
Um, however, you know, they, they're a subset within the reality overlay of, of the demiurge of the, of the reality overlay itself, which is built on the DNA.
So as, as difficult as that is to see, because that requires looking at things from a very different perspective, not from a human perspective, but from a bottom up perspective, as opposed to from a human out perspective.
Um, but when you're able to switch perspectives, that's, that's what you'll see.
Is there anything, um, well, I don't think there's anything about that in the material, Morgan.
Can you think of any material that has, uh, any relevance to the rest of this?
And the scene Herm is good.
I mean, I'm not taken away from him.
I mean, he's a very interesting thinker.
Oh, yeah.
Whatever.
I mean, I can't pronounce people's names.
I can barely, as, as everyone can tell, I can barely speak English.
Nevermind, like, pronouncing names and shit like that.
It gets, it's very difficult.
So please excuse me if I mispronounce things.
Go ahead, Morgan.
I'm going to go, no, just, um, the only reason I brought it up is because it, it sounded very similar to, to the mechanism that you were describing.
And, uh, by the way, I did post, uh, just a really quick, uh, it's about a one minute clip of, of him talking about it.
I posted up in the nest.
Um, if you've ever taken art, I mean, I assume we all took art classes, right?
In school, even though most of us aren't artists.
Well, actually maybe everyone here is an artist, but me, I'm not an artist, right?
But the idea of negative space is very important and the feedback loops and physical principles are the negative space of reality, as we understand it.
So the feedback loops are very important.
Um, there's something we don't see directly, but they shape everything because they're the, the vessels and containers, which reality fits in, to use that metaphor.
Um, argom, go ahead, I'm sorry, I don't know your full handle, I just see argom, argom moo, argom moo, I feel like you asked to speak and I kicked you up to speaker, you're there, did you take a break?
What, uh, I don't even know what he said.
Did he say that's the truth or it's not the truth?
We've got the truth!
Alright, I think, um, I think you're going through something and you might want to step down, um, because I don't know if we can understand what you're saying with the dogs barking in the background.
Nor do I know if this is a legitimate comment or, you know, if, um, if it's not.
Go ahead.
Are you going to do the, the truth of the dog barking again?
Okay.
Are you perhaps, maybe the dog is the one making the comments.
I don't know, weirder things have happened.
This is UFOX, so maybe, maybe the dog is actually the one who's, who's speaking.
So yeah, when we get into like the UFO reality itself, we come full circle.
That's what we, we would look at, right?
So we would look at the UFOs representing, um, a certain amount of the experiences.
The UFOs representing the archons and archonic avatars, um, that may be here for observation and study, right?
Because one, as Morgan and I talk about all the time, like once you have a reality overlay, once you have an experiment, because that's what we're talking.
We're talking about an, uh, an experiment, an awful experiment, but an experiment.
Um, once you have an experiment like this, uh, your goal would be to take that data set and maximize the number of applications, um, that you could find for the data itself.
Um, so if you have, um, a sim, if there is a simulation aspect to the reality overlay, um, then much like we think about AI, um, simulating experiments for us and coming to conclusions for like developing medicines, you could look at our technological development and our experiments within the reality overlay.
As being tasked in some way, or perhaps emergent, but the, the people outside the reality overlay would possibly be taking the technology that we developed as a model here and finding practical applications for it outside of the reality overlay, which would be one of the reasons that they would be studying our scientific achievements and studying our scientists to the extent that they were.
Um, it would also be, um, it would also be, uh, a very good, so the explanation that is often given that aliens come from a planet, uh, far away in a spaceship and then crash that spaceship, um, and kill a bunch of clones so that they can seed technology for us.
And, um, and take the DNA when they could, um, and take the DNA when they could do that anyhow with the technology they have.
Like, uh, for a lot of people that doesn't really, that's a story that doesn't, doesn't really stick for us, right?
It doesn't, it doesn't sound plausible on some level.
Um, another way of, of looking at that though, is from the perspective we're talking about makes a lot more sense.
And the thing about the reality overlay is once you accept it, it, it makes sense of everything.
It's, it is a universal theory.
Um, honestly, there's nothing that it doesn't improve.
There's no inexplicable situation.
It doesn't make sense of.
So introducing a model of external technology into a reality overlay through the crashing of these avatars,
you know, created within, right?
Within our atmosphere or outside of our atmosphere, what we perceive to be our atmosphere in the reality overlay crashed, retrieved.
Um, they don't want, this is just to be clear.
Um, the archons do not want people knowing that we're in a reality overlay.
Um, it can't be avoided at this point.
Um, they specifically want to distract people from that realization, not because you have any power.
You don't, you're, you're in a false reality.
Uh, it's because they don't want people preparing for the eventuality of death.
So that's a different story.
We've done a number of, um, spaces on that and we'll do more in the future, but that is what the evidence seems to suggest.
They don't want people spending time preparing for the eventuality of death.
Um, and so, uh, they try to distract people.
Um, however, uh, if you take this, uh, model, basically if they're creating a model, you know, just like we would create a model of a ship on a desk, they create an avatar model of a saucer, they crash it.
Um, those of us, if you've ever seen the Rick and Morty where they've got the simulation is his car batteries, a simulation and they're in there working, you know, we've got all these subjective hours of time that we're just sort of hanging around.
Why not task that with technological innovation?
It would make a lot of sense.
And then we, we take that technology, we work on it, we generalize it, we create new forms for it.
They swoop in and grab that.
And now they have new inventions that they can use, um, outside of the reality overlay.
So that's one, that's not the purpose of the experiment as far as we understand it, but it certainly is consistent with the data that Morgan's group has.
And it's also consistent with the data that other remote viewing, uh, remote viewers who, um, who look at this subject or come upon this subject inadvertently have.
Um, I know I was talking to, uh, Sasha from magic and the noise yesterday or the day before, and, um, their group has, um, some session work on the pole shift and from their, from the perception or the perception, from the perspective of their work, the pole shift.
It's basically rebooting the experiment is the internal experience of the external act of rebooting the experiment.
And there's a degaussing where everyone, or not everyone, but the majority, the vast majority about 14,999 out of 15,000 people to give you an idea of what I mean by the majority.
Um, um, in her work are degaussed, or, um, have their memories erased, uh, magnetically in a way that mirrors a degaussing effect of having, uh, one of these, those old, uh, disks, um, erased with a magnet.
Um, and she actually saw, or her team saw, uh, people working on the experiment.
I don't know if she would use those terms.
I'm not trying to put words in her mouth, but that's, those are the words I'm using.
Um, take the information from the experiments being conducted in the reality overlay in the form of a physical object, something similar to a computer disk,
and set it on a shelf, um, during the process of the pole shift, um, which was basically resetting the experiment.
So all that information was stored, uh, so the data could be retrieved for using purposes outside of the reality overlay.
So that would be one form of paranormal interaction, but the other forms of paranormal interaction could be communication from nature, right?
The demiurge in the form of, of nature, which is a collective distributed intelligence and DNA, um, the communication from the collective unconscious of network to human beings, communication from your own unconscious.
Then there is the possibility of intruders, which we would cover, right?
Where we have, could have beings not related to the archons possibly break in, in a sense, to this reality overlay, possibly.
Um, and there is data to support the existence and perception of non-physical, non-human intelligence that one might term demonic as, as being real and being something experienced within the reality overlay.
So, um, the other possibility, um, would be that the reality overlay is larger than the planet that we perceive and could include other planets in the solar system and things we don't perceive.
Um, and that there could be other, this is, I don't know if this is anywhere in Morgan's data, but it is something to think about, uh, speculate on that perhaps there are other, there are aliens that exist inside the reality overlay the same way we exist inside the reality overlay.
Um, and that's possible there's, you know, there's, you know, there's, you know, I know Dan has speculated that perhaps the reality overlay is the size of a galaxy.
I don't think so.
It just, but that's just a hunch.
There's no evidence to say that it's not.
Um, so there very well could be EBE 11s and Ebons showing up here, um, but they might be just as phony as we are and represent either something internal to the reality overlay, just like a non-player character represents something internal to a game.
Um, or, um, they could represent other species in another place, another planet in the, in the universe at base level who have also been enslaved in the reality overlay themselves.
So there are a number of explanations for the paranormal.
When you get into the hypothetical explanations that fit with the reality overlay concept, when you get into like, what is definitely most likely.
The weirdness generated by either someone mischievous screwing around with us or coming as a, as a message, an archetype from nature or the collective intelligence, collective unconscious, you're getting into paranormal, non-UFO related stuff.
Like UFOs from the, from the Jungian perspective, UFOs from the McKenna, the perspective of Terrence McKenna, those type of experiences, synchronistic UFO experiences, but you'd also be looking at cryptids, Bigfoot, right?
Like Loch Ness monster, um, things that keep appearing, but then seem to disappear.
And when remote viewers look at those, many remote viewers will see them popping in and out of reality.
So being generated inside, either outside the reality overlay and projected into it, or being generated inside the reality overlay and then, and ceasing to exist for a period of time and then being generated again.
So that really weird paranormal stuff, that's almost certainly an artifact of our collective unconscious in this reality overlay is almost certainly.
Um, I do believe Bigfoot is real.
I, I believe Bigfoot is real and I believe that they're going to drag one out of the forest one of these days, but I don't necessarily believe all cryptids are present in actual populations.
Um, I think that that, that a lot of that is autogen, uh, through this, this collective dream that we're living in.
And this particular iteration of the dream, because one of the aspects of the theory that Morgan and I work with is that this is just one iteration of the reality overlay.
This is one dream.
If you imagine someone having a night full of dreams, this is the most recent dream that we're having, but we're in the same period of sleep.
Um, and we would look at potentially other realities, other historical periods, even hypothetically, uh, we would look at those as possibly other dreams we've had prior to this one collectively.
I don't know if anyone has any questions, comments, concerns, um, aside from the dog barking, I didn't really know what was going on with that one, but.
Um, I sent you a co-host invitation.
I've been co attempting to get everyone to co-host, but, uh, for some reason they won't let me assign a co-host.
Uh, Joseph, go on, man.
Take it away, Joseph.
Good.
One thing that really popped up in my mind about the, uh, Neanderthal genetics introduced into this is, uh, uh, the individual that goes by the pseudonym of Seth, uh, Paribson on here.
And he actually did a deep dive into, uh, how, uh, Neanderthal DNA predisposes you to, um, to having, uh, a lack of immunity to a fungal infection.
And, uh, it was interesting because you're talking about how trees actually communicate and they have the mycelial network.
Uh, mycelium is the, uh, actual, what mushrooms are and the, what we think of mushrooms are, I know you know this, the reproductive organ of the, uh, mycelium.
And, uh, it's interesting because when people do a thing called the, they call it the NAC protocol and they start to rid themselves of the, uh, fungus, they actually, uh, get a releasing of their, it seems to suppress the, your natural DNT.
Which, uh, when, when that happens, they actually get spontaneous, uh, psychic phenomenon, spontaneous astral projection, clairvoyance, like Claire's, that sort of stuff.
And, uh, uh, that seems to me to be, and I know you, you guys are looking into, uh, the ways that we are suppressed and you look up, you know, that we are, um, uh, you know, pretty much your entire dialogue and it's obviously correct.
But, but I think, uh, I think that is an interesting thing to point out.
I had another point, but I totally forgot it.
Sorry, I'm just at my break.
Just take a, just take a second and it'll come back to you.
So the interesting thing about that is that Neanderthal DNA, right, is, um, or Neanderthals themselves are, are a cold weather adapt or were a cold weather adapted hominid.
Um, so it would make sense to be honest, that their genetics would be less focused on dealing with fungal infections.
Um, one of the benefits that we get from living in cold areas is that we suffer far fewer fungal infections because the cold kills off the fungus every year.
Um, and fewer environmental infections to begin by, fewer parasitical infections, fewer environmental mediated infections.
So it would make sense that they had less resistance to fungal infections.
They wouldn't have run into it.
Whereas if you think of like a tropical environment where you're basically in a soup all day, you're just loaded with fungus everywhere.
And if you were adapted to living in a tropical environment, if you were a hominid and adapted in that environment for 300,000 years or 3 million years, you would definitely probably have adapted more resistance to fungus or else you'd be dead.
Right.
Um, one of the things that they talk about right now, this is a digression, but, um, the danger of a looming fungal.
Um, and I'm going to say this, this is off topic, but, um, as an astrologer, I'm going to tell you that, uh, people should be concerned about a looming fungal epidemic or, or pandemic, um, because it's clearly something that is indicated astrologically over the next 20 years as being a possibility.
Uh, getting back to, um, to what the scientists say, um, they blame it on global warming.
I'm not a proponent of anthropogenic global warming myself.
Um, I'm not a climate scientist either.
Um, however, I, I don't, I was prior to, um, that theory.
So I remember prior to it, um, and I have other theories that I learned when I was very young that, that I think make more sense.
Uh, that having been said, what they're saying is that the world is getting warmer and because the world is getting warmer, um, that puts us in danger of, um, more fungal infections.
Uh, I don't know if it's, if that is actual one of the, actually one of the reasons it's happening.
Uh, however, anecdotally right around the time, uh, Pluto went into Aquarius last year, which is the, you know, not to distract everyone with astrology when they didn't show up here for astrology.
Um, that is, uh, one of the, um, yeah.
So right around that time, uh, they were like a bunch of very public examples of strange mushrooms and funguses growing in people around the planet.
Not in mass numbers, isolated individuals in different places who suddenly developed infections from fungi that weren't supposed to infect human beings.
It was again, blame the global warming.
We could all agree that there are probably other reasons why it might be happening.
Right.
Um, it is part of like the disclosure community.
I think everyone is, is naturally adapted to suspect that there are possibly other factors that are being kept from people to explain almost anything.
Um, yeah, so in that sense, we would be experiencing our, our lack of adaptation to ward off fungal infection, like people who adapted to live in the tropics or the Northern, um, areas of Africa, for instance, uh, that could put us into a, a real disadvantage going forward with one of these super fungi, um, infections.
However, like you were saying, right.
He puts it to about, go ahead.
Oh, well, he, he put it to about 40,000 years ago after studying, uh, hominid teeth when, uh, the infection started really coming out.
Yeah.
I mean, that's the time that's often cited because we have a problem because we believe in the reality overlay.
We have a problem with history.
And then I think I've explained this in other sessions.
You've, you've been part of Joseph.
Um, once you accept it's like.
Um, you know, when I was younger, I remember people bagging on creationists and there was a tremendous amount of work put into demonstrating.
And there has been for about a hundred years or more, a tremendous amount of scientific work put into demonstrating that it's not possible.
The earth could be created, uh, because of the age of everything.
And supposedly the earth was created 5,000 years ago.
I don't think that's actually, I don't think that's, that's a timetable that was put together.
Um, however, you know, if you look at the belief in a young earth, um, they would dismiss it by saying there can't be a young earth because there are radioactive isotopes that are very old in the atmosphere.
Things like that.
Um, those are all non sequiturs.
That's, and, and, and strawman arguments.
And they never made any sense.
Uh, the people who defended young earth creationism were just, I mean, no offense to them.
I'm sure they're perfectly wonderful people.
They weren't the most intelligent people.
They were intellectually sloppy and none of them ever seized on the obvious fact that any God that could create a planet.
Right, uh, and fill it with life could create an old planet and fill it with life.
When we create a video game and we set it in Hong Kong, we don't set it in a Hong Kong that, you know, sprang into existence yesterday.
We set it in a Hong Kong that is, exists in a video game world that is ostensibly, you know, in a universe that's 14 billion years old.
It's the same thing.
Um, and when you get into, um, simulation theory and the reality overlay, they often call it creationism for nerds, right?
That's, that's the app.
The accusation is often made.
It's just creationism adapted to, to, um, technophiles and, and there's, and there's a, there's a truth to that because the basic principles apply.
Um, whoever created the reality overlay to whatever scent we created it ourselves.
And it was created for us by those who have put us here.
Uh, it could have been at any time and the earth could be any age when that happened.
Right.
So the reality overlay could have been created 50,000 years ago and the earth could have, you know, on base level could be, you know, 14 billion years old, whatever, 4 billion years old, whatever it is.
Um, but we don't know how long the reality overlay has been around, right?
So we don't know what artifacts were actually artifacts that existed inside the reality overlay and they're part.
What artifacts are part of the reality overlay itself that we've been in imprisoned in.
Um, so when you talk about like 50,000 years ago, I think we're talking about like stuff that happened outside the reality overlay.
And I don't know if it was really 50,000 years ago, like 50,000 subjective years inside the reality overlay.
Like it gets complicated to phrase things like that semantically, but that's what we do.
Um, but yes, it was around that time.
Like our subjective dating of the, the interbreeding with Neanderthals and Denisovans is about 50,000 to 30,000 years ago.
And that's when you see all the changes begin.
And that's when you see the hybrid skeletons show up.
And that's like what you're talking about with the dental records that would be homo sapiens or Neanderthal.
I don't know.
I think you were talking about Neanderthals, but there would be, you know, homo sapiens, um, hybrids who were learning to live with Neanderthal DNA, uh, and developing those problems.
There are problems from the Neanderthal DNA.
Absolutely.
Like we have, um, cystic fibrosis.
We have, uh, osteoarthritis is a big problem connected to Neanderthal DNA.
Um, there are a number of them, uh, but the genes are conserved because, well, I mean, everyone knows this, but I'm not, I don't mean to talk down anyone, but you know, it's natural selection is all about getting you to mating, right?
Getting you to be, uh, to have children and be a parent.
Um, and after that, what's that?
Sexual selection, right?
Well, sexual selection, there's different types of selection.
What I'm saying is that, um, the genes are conserved to get us to a certain point in our life, not to keep us healthy for our whole life.
That's like a different, there's a, there are some people who believe the opposite.
They believe like in a pristine genetic environment, our genes are designed to keep us healthy until we're a hundred years old.
And that's just not, that's just fucking nonsense.
It's, they're designed to get us healthy to about 30.
And then after that you fall apart because you're designed to fall apart.
Um, even if we live longer, we would still have a period.
Or you're not, you're not designed to actually carry on, right?
Right.
Like there, there's no pressure to actually do it.
So it's not like it's intentionally done that just there, there's no more use for it.
I've heard of that before.
Sure.
I mean, um, yeah, that's, that's how natural selection works.
Yeah.
Go on.
Well, I mean, when you're talking about like the fabrication of the, or the creation of the reality overlay, you know, I wonder what, if there are limitations because we are put into it, is there something of us that creates a limitation on the worlds that can create, they can create.
And also like, it really puts a big problem because if, like you said, if you could just, and it kind of really does make sense.
If you look at all of the points of history of what we know that, you know, I don't know, I can't really make a definitive narrative on it, but that it just seems like it's kind of obvious that everything was kind of created to look old.
And, uh, a lot of things don't really line up and it's kind of weird because like, we don't have a linear sequential history that we're dealing with.
And then we don't know, uh, how does that impact how we look at the future?
Because, you know, if they, what are their limitations?
We don't know what can they create in the future.
And then it seems like right now that we're living in a world where, um, there are a whole bunch of different factions, um, trying to change the future.
And then there are archons who are coming in and then they are, uh, making changes as well and doing guidance.
But then you have the system itself, which they just do a reset on it, you know?
So, uh, I don't know if that's a, no, those are a real question.
Those are, those are good points.
So the way that works, it seems, um, and I don't know if this is covered in, in the intuitive underground data.
There's a tremendous amount of intuitive underground data that I have yet to see.
And, you know, Morgan, they're, they're smart guys, Morgan and Dan.
Um, but this is like a over 10 year, you know, project with all kinds of session data, you know, hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of pages of session data.
So they have to sort of review it.
And Morgan didn't have a chance to review it before this session.
It's my fault.
We were having technical difficulties in discord and I forgot to send him a message.
Um, it was a hundred percent on me.
Uh, however, like prior to something like this, he would generally go through and review all the data that's pertinent to it, uh, to make sure that he was giving accurate data.
And because it's difficult to remember at all.
Um, as far as, uh, like why, how is, I'm sorry, refresh one more, just one more time.
Tell me one more time.
What was it?
Cause I'm getting old too.
Um, what was the, the basic point of your statement?
Just, just for, I'm not being condescending.
I just don't remember it.
I just have a minor, um, brain fart.
Oh, you're gone.
Shit.
Hold on.
I'm going to bring Joseph up for a second.
Then I'll take you.
Cause he's go ahead, Joseph.
I'm talking to you.
You're not even there.
That shows you how out of it I am.
Go on.
He's gone.
He's gone again.
Oh, it'll, it'll, it takes a second because when you're a listener, you're on like a,
whatever it is, a seven and a live broadcast delay.
So.
Dan, we'll get to you in just a second.
Joseph's going to, Joseph, can you just hit me with that point again?
So I can, I can respond to it.
Cause I lost, I lost the, I lost the plot.
All right.
Sorry.
I had a.
That's okay.
It's me.
I should have remembered.
No, no, that's fine.
Like, how do we judge the future knowing that they can just reconstruct this any way they
want at any time?
That's a great point.
Uh, yeah.
No future.
Yeah.
There's, there's no future.
The future isn't real.
Neither is the past.
Right.
I mean, to a certain extent it is.
We run into this all the time, just with the way people look at the past.
Right.
So just talking about the past in terms of our lifetime, it's almost impossible because
the majority of people harbor the, the, the false belief that things that didn't happen
are just as real as things that did.
So they have a view of the past where like, that's where the idea of multiple realities
comes from.
They have a view of the past where like they turned right and they wound up making $50,000
a year, you know, getting a job with me, $50,000 a year.
But if they had that same corner had turned left and gone into a different storefront,
they would be Elon Musk right now.
They want to believe that it is only through coincidence and random decisions that their
life is what it is, as opposed to being something different.
That isn't in accord with the concept of reality overlay.
It's not in accord with the concept of reality, right?
Because reality is by definition, only what is reality can never include by definition
that which isn't.
So when physicists talk about multiple realities, they're being disingenuous and they're playing
games with definitions.
The things that happen in your life, that's reality.
The things that didn't happen, that's not reality.
It's not real.
As far as the future is concerned.
So there's really no past.
It's kind of a past, right?
It's the only past is exactly what happened.
And there is no future from the perspective of like science fiction, like that future.
That is more than likely something that may exist at base level or is us laboring away,
uncompensated for the archons and coming up with data for them.
However, we will be reset prior to that ever occurring.
And that reset happens through periodic catastrophe.
Getting more tongue-tied.
Periodic catastrophes, as everyone might be familiar with, because it's been in the collective conscious
recently, you know, it's every 6,400 years.
And then there's a big one every 12,800 years.
And it alternates every 12,800 years between the cataclysmus, which is a period of flooding
and freezing, and the ekipirosis.
This is according to the Greeks and the Egyptians, which is a period of intense heat and the destruction,
periodic destruction of society by fire.
So it'd be volcanism and actual fires and solar activity.
And according to everything we know about the pattern of those events, we are in the beginning
stages of one right now.
It would last up to 1,200 years.
But even 300 years from now, there shouldn't be really any trace of this civilization.
And that's 300 subjective years.
However, narrowing it down, they believe that much of the activity occurs in a 15-year period
at the very beginning.
And that would start around March of this year.
So just based on what we do know about what we perceive as history, it's very likely that
a lot of this civilization won't be around even in 15 years, but it certainly won't be around
in 300 years.
So the Federation of Planets is something that's got to be left for base-level reality and not
something that's going to exist in the reality overlay.
Go ahead, Dan.
Yeah, thanks for bringing me up here.
I was back to the Denisovans and the Neanderthals and whatnot.
Do you know of any way that we've aged any of the skeletons we found outside of not meaning
in aging when they existed, but how old they were other than comparing them to human growth?
How old they were when they died?
Yeah, exactly.
Like whether they were 20 years or 150 or 500 years.
Yeah, they definitely have that information.
I don't have that information.
I have heard on more than one occasion, I've heard people suggest that there's evidence that
some of them were extremely long-lived, but I don't know if that's real and not like
just a story somebody created.
I think...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I know with Neanderthals particularly, right, when they find their skeletons, I think that
they tend to live, if they can, about the same length as a human being or at least 50 years.
However, most of them didn't.
And the reason that is often given is that they had a strange hunting style, which was
more of an ambush hunting style.
The human beings get together and chase the animals down, which is our advantage.
And then when the animals are tired, you know, we're not tired because we're endurance runners.
And then we are able to kill the animals.
What the Neanderthals did was kind of blend in with groups of animals and then on a predetermined
time, jump on them and stab them to death.
That's what's believed.
And there's a tremendous amount of evidence because the average Neanderthal skeleton shows
the same type and extent of damage as a rodeo clown.
Like very, very similar damage to that as sustained by a rodeo clown during his career.
And...
Pretty beaten, huh?
Yeah.
From getting thrown around by the animals, kicked and thrown and stomped on.
And so they didn't live very long for that reason.
However, we do know they experienced empathy and took care of the disabled because they do
find skeletons in their small communities.
They very often find skeletons of people who were older, like older than 30, but were clearly
disabled.
So it had to have been kept alive for a certain period of time through the charity of others.
Now, where does Younger Dryas fall into this history?
Younger Dryas would be like way after that was over, the hybrid is...
I mean, again...
I mean, in regards to the cataclysmic cycle.
That's the cataclysmus.
Okay.
So the Younger Dryas, the way that worked out, so they still haven't decided whether it
was volcanoes, comets, or like micro nova, right?
The predominant theory, as far as I know, is comets.
It's still...
That's not mainstream science.
Like a lot of mainstream science doesn't even really look at just a change in climate.
They don't look at like a precipitating factor, right?
But as you probably know, the evidence for that is the tiny diamonds that are found in
that layer of soil throughout North America and Greenland would indicate some sort of event
that is either ascribed to cometary impacts or volcanism.
I think cometary impacts are the ones that make the most sense.
And there's clearly at least one giant crater in Greenland under the ice sheet.
And so to the best of my knowledge, the dominant theory is there were a series of cometary impacts
related to the same comet that was broken up and would come back and impact in a regular
period of time.
One of those impacts was really large and hit the either Greenland or the Laurentian ice sheet
in Northern Canada and melted all the water.
But the water was bound up within the glaciers, which were still strong enough to form a wall
and led to a period of cooling.
Well, there was a period of...
So it was cold.
There were the impacts.
The biggest impact melted the water.
And then when the temperature itself started to rise around the planet, that caused a big
problem because then the internal flood, yeah, dumped out a whole bunch of water.
And this is actually something where almost no one knows what the fuck they're talking about.
I'm going to tell you right now, like you can go on Twitter and you can find all the people
talk about the pole shift and they all forget basic high school science because they don't
teach it anymore.
And we're all getting older, right?
So everyone forgets crustal displacement.
So just to be quick, right?
Yeah.
So when the ice melts after an ice age, it causes a change in the altitude of the land masses
involved.
So the weight of the ice pushes down the land mass into the mantle because it's a liquid mantle.
So during the ice age, ground level is lower with this ice.
But at the periphery, right at the edge of the glacier areas, that land is pushed up by
this displacement, just like if you push down on a sponge with your finger, the area around
it seems to rise up, right?
It doesn't with the sponge.
But in this case, it really does because it's a liquid mantle.
So when the ice melts, the area under the ice rises hundreds of feet and the area around
the edge falls hundreds of feet and it happens very quickly.
So that's part of the flood.
And one of the reasons that it was possible to have a global flood at that time, but it
is not possible now, is that during the period of the ice age, a lot of the water is on land.
The bottom of the seafloor rises up.
It rises up by miles.
So the sea isn't deep enough to hold the melted water until the pressure of the water pushes
down the seabed in the liquid mantle.
So when that flood happened, the seabed was not low enough to absorb it all.
It was the weight of the water over the course of, we've been told 40 days, but it could be
years, that pushed down the seabed and made room for the water and left the land dry.
That's a fact, scientifically.
People can argue all they want, but they measure it still to this day.
The areas like New England, which used to be covered with glaciers, rise a tiny bit, a
little tiny bit, like less than a centimeter every year.
But every year we rise still.
And it's because the land is still adjusting to the lack of the weight of the ice.
It's just been a long time.
Every year, the seafloor falls a little bit, maybe a centimeter, maybe a little bit
more than a centimeter, less than an inch.
Because it's still to this day, adjusting to the changing weight of the water.
So when they talk about like pole shift today versus pole shift 12,000 years ago, when they
say like, this is what happened 12,000 years ago.
Therefore, this is what's going to happen now.
They're not accounting for crustal displacement.
They don't remember it.
They don't believe in it.
They don't know about it.
They think the ocean is as deep as it is and it never changes.
They think the land is as high as it is and it never changes.
And therefore, the events are always going to be the same and they're not.
To make a long story short or a short story long.
What do we got?
Morgan, did you see anything about flooding?
I know you did.
You did see stuff about flooding with the pole shift, right?
But I don't remember exactly how much you saw.
And I know it's sort of going off on a tangent.
Yeah, look, me personally, I've only done very, very preliminary work into the pole shift.
And I never pursued it any further because I, at least at that time, I didn't see much point
in really going.
My intention was to either verify or debunk it as a concept.
And I was more than satisfied that the work had verified it as legitimate.
And I didn't take it any further.
So I, it would be pure speculation with no real foundational basis, you know, if I were
given a specific.
So we'll decline.
Okay, fair enough.
I know what I see when I look at other viewers' work, when I'm auditing the work of other
viewers posted publicly online.
From that and their predictions, along with the predictions given in the past by past seers
and prophets in a non-religious sense, I think that there should be a period of flooding involved
this time.
But I don't think that it involves what pole shift advocates are predicting, which is a giant
wave.
It could.
I'm not an expert, but they, they keep predicting that the earth is going to shift a certain number
of degrees and that the inertia is going to cause a giant wave to rise up and wash over
the continents.
I don't, um, I don't necessarily think that has to be what happens.
I think that it's quite possible that the water just wells up in this instance, um, and it
would be flooding like a flood as opposed to flooding, like a, a world spanning giant tsunami
that washes around the world and wipes everything out.
And if you think about it, if there was a world, uh, uh, spanning 4,000 foot tsunami that
happened every 12,000 years or every 6,400 years, there would not be life on this planet.
It just wouldn't be, it wouldn't be possible.
They can keep receding it, but it just wouldn't be possible for the life to continue on the
planet in that situation.
Even if people went underground, that would just be too much.
Uh, it would wipe everything out.
When people came up, what would they eat?
It wouldn't be anything to eat.
Right.
So they have to have, what, 500 years worth of food or some crazy shit like that.
Um, cause there would be salinity in the soil, right?
So it's not just like you come out of the cave and, and grow the shit.
There'd be the salinity.
And so, I mean, there would just be, it just doesn't make sense.
There definitely are like, there are seashells found at the top of mountains, but again,
crust of displacement can explain that as well as a tidal wave.
Um, however, that does seem that other viewers see mass flooding.
They definitely don't see the entire world flooded.
They see something closer to like the Gordon Michael Scallion map.
Um, if you're familiar with that or the IAM map from the eighties, um, which is just less
land, more flooding, but still land existing, um, in other areas.
Haven't we verified, uh, flood myths and pretty much every culture on the planet though?
Well, yeah, absolutely.
Um, what I'm pointing out is that there's not necessarily the same type of flood every,
every 400 years, every 12,000.
Different floods, different places, different lengths of time.
Right.
And particularly now where, um, there's very little water, uh, frozen on the landmass.
The ocean is very deep.
Um, and the land is very high.
I don't, I just don't know if it would be the same way it was before.
I mean, most of what was destroyed in the past was flooded out is now is still underwater.
Right.
So that's what I find what they, I mean, they argue what they claim is not ruins, but you
definitely can find them off the coast of Japan.
Um, and in the Bahamas, uh, because right now the ocean level is still 300 feet higher
than it was, um, at the end of the, uh, Yunga Dryas.
Right.
The water's already there.
I don't know.
I just don't think it's going to be the same.
We'll see.
I mean, we'll know because we're all going to die together if there's a giant tidal wave
on the planet.
Right.
So I kind of feel like it's like revelations, like all these things happening at once, including
everybody fighting with each other.
All right.
Well, that's a hundred percent.
I mean, that's, you know, what we always talk about.
Um, and we have a friend who is very good at predicting solar cycles and has predicted,
uh, Muhammad, I keep trying to bring you up, but you're not popping up and I'm not sure
why, but that's not something I'm doing.
It seems to be a problem with, uh, X spaces itself.
I just didn't want you to think that I wasn't bringing you up.
I I'm, I'm hitting, bring you up.
And then some reason it's not happening.
Um,
save God, the banner.
What's that?
It's the save Gaza banner.
Grok is, uh, XAI is actively censoring.
Oh, sure.
Yeah.
No, you know what?
That very well could be, you very well could be right.
I know that, um, I've done previous spaces where I said things that were public knowledge,
but perhaps not something that people are supposed to say.
And they cut out every time.
I'm like, just, they crash it right away.
You try writing synagogue of Satan in your post and see how long it's been.
Just synagogue of Satan.
Okay.
Yeah.
I understand what you're saying.
I wouldn't do that.
Yeah.
No, it's scripture.
I get you.
I know what scripture, I know what it is.
I know what it means.
I'm saying I wouldn't, I wouldn't go out of my way to do that.
Um, but I can understand that, you know, Grok would certainly, um, yeah, they wouldn't allow
that to happen.
So, yeah, we definitely do see flooding.
We don't see, um, don't see the same, um, amount of flooding, uh, that they talk about
during the Younger Dryas period.
Um, I think that one of the precursors to that, and this isn't just something remote viewers
have said that remote viewers have said this, but, uh, non, non-religious people,
the prophets, and, and I think Jesus said it too, right?
When he said, well, what's going to happen in the end times is going to be, um, you know,
talked about the, the, the fear for the waters, right, uh, in the oceans.
And I'm, I'm not going to say, I'm not going to try to quote it because I don't remember
it exactly, but you know what I'm saying?
Like there's definitely, uh, um, ocean related issues in the end times.
Um, I think that, uh, the war is something that happens first.
And I think what we have seen and what we can reason out is that the escalation towards
global war seems to parallel, um, this natural disaster, but that's definitely something that's
a lot of viewers to say, going back to the guy who originally took remote viewing private
Ed Dames, right?
He talked about that for years, the kill shot, um, in video format on the radio, it's very
well attested in remote viewing circles, um, that immediately prior to a solar event slash
pole shift scenario, there would be an outbreak of global warfare.
And it makes sense because once the governments know that they're going to be competing with
each other for scarce resources after a massive crisis, at that point, reason would say, and
I'm not saying it's right.
I'm just saying cold reason alone would say the best thing to do would be to limit the competition
after the natural disaster.
Now, while you have strength rather than wait to see what type of technology and what type
of weapons you have after the disaster, right?
Like from a, from a military perspective, from a, from a national perspective, and I'm not
backing this up on, I'm not saying it's, it's moral.
What I'm saying is when you're in that scenario where you think that you're going to experience
like a mass mass death, the end of civilization, um, you know, the, the worst scenario would
be for your country to emerge weak and to have another country emerge in a stronger position
because, you know, they could, they're very likely to come to the conclusion.
I mean, they would come to the conclusion that the right thing to do is to be, to wipe everyone
else out and, and save the resources for themselves so they could try to get through.
So I believe it's, it's almost certain that, you know, we'd see the outbreak of very serious
warfare immediately prior to that type of disaster.
And when our friend, uh, had predicted that this was going to happen in late June, um, he's
very good.
He has a system of predicting solar events that I think is probably the most advanced on
earth.
Um, but I didn't, I never thought that it was actually going to happen in late June
because it didn't line up with any military activity, right?
The, the, the escalation.
Yeah.
So it would be something that would happen like, and we do have a remote viewer friend, uh,
Josh Maitland of rockstar remote viewing who was tasked with, um, Morgan and I are the
originators of Astro RV, at least in its modern form.
Morgan is the individual responsible for making that happen.
So you're going to say, who's the creator?
It's Morgan.
Um, some individuals potentially inspired by us, but maybe having the idea on their own.
And I guess that, that who knows, right?
They would say sort of their own idea.
And listen, this type of idea people could have, right?
It's not, I mean, as Morgan was saying at the beginning of this, like Ingo, Ingo Swan
had the idea himself.
So, um, they did, uh, an Astro RV session, um, based on, um, a transit in August and the
transit, the individual, Dan Waits, the astrologer is not someone I'm a hundred percent on.
I have some, some issues with him, but in this sense, he did a very good job of picking a
good transit, um, on August 9th.
And he tasked, um, uh, Josh to look at the August 9th date, but he, he didn't have any
experience.
Dan didn't have any experience doing remote viewing prompts.
So he wrote this extremely open-ended prompt that basically included everything that the
events on August 9th and everything that, that follows from them.
Right.
It's like August 9th would be the first domino and he had Josh target all the dominoes.
So we don't know how far in the future Josh saw.
Um, however, his, the things he saw were very much in accord with the things that the
the profits and Sears have seen very much in accord with things, other remote viewers have
seen.
Um, and that includes a war and that includes a, a coastal flooding scenario and a natural
disaster.
It includes UFOs being present, um, in large numbers.
Uh, and all of that would follow from the events of August 9th and around that period of
time.
So it could be something that starting in August and then through the end of this year,
we would see a series of crazy events or it could be what I'm hoping, which is like a
year and a half.
Now I know people don't like to hear that because a lot of people like, well, 2040, I don't
think so.
I think that we're going to see like some pretty severe civilizational changes in the next year
and a half.
And I'm saying that as an astrologer based on the astrology.
Um, and I think the remote viewers back it up.
So after that period, and I never thought anything would happen prior to August 9th, to be completely
honest with you, um, but we do think it will be solar related.
And so I contacted him.
His name is Patrick Carroll, and he is still looking for information to narrow down the
date.
I'm not a guy who like needs to know the day.
What I've said in previous spaces stands.
I think that we should all not worry about what day this is going to happen, but worry about
learning, um, the escalatory ladder that we would expect to see.
So that in the event that these things start to go down, we can make logical decisions about
when the right time to potentially relocate or hoard toilet paper, whatever it is.
Like when is the reasonable time to behave like that?
And when is it self-destructive behavior?
So that's what I focus on as opposed to the day itself.
Would you look towards scripture for any of those prophecies?
I think that, um, well, it's okay.
This is where, like, this is.
Okay.
It seems like a lot of these things fall right in line with revelation.
Yeah.
Uh, prophecy as well.
And whether you're a believer or not, I think people, like, I think atheists should take
that into account because.
And they do.
They line up with seers.
They do.
The majority of Americans, at least 10 years ago, 20 years ago, the majority of Americans,
including atheists and new agers, believed in the book of revelations.
Um, there was a book, there are several books written about, by, about Howard Bloom on this,
about how the book of revelations was basically taking over the American religious worldview.
Um, however, yes, I'm a Christian and I am a New Testament Christian.
I am not an Old Testament Christian and there is a difference.
Um, so the eschatology, the way that I would look at eschatology would vary significantly from
someone say in, um, in a Old Testament forward, Old Testament oriented, uh, Christian church
in Oklahoma.
Now there are some people here who did not come here at all for religion.
Right.
And so it's not that I don't, I'm not forward with what I believe, but I don't want to hijack
anyone.
Right.
I'm not trying to set anyone up to come and hear about the paranormal and then get, you know,
or, right, this isn't, um, this isn't like that.
Okay.
Um, so I'm not going to talk.
I have offered to do, um, offered to do a revelations, um, say space.
If people want it, there's been some interest.
And if that is still the case, we're going to do it after August 7th because we're lined
up until then with spaces.
But after that, around the time the shit might hit the fan, we'll be looking for other spaces
and I'm perfectly willing to do a revelations space there to be contentious because there
are a number of different interpretations.
However, um, in short, what I believe is the events of revelations, uh, began in, um, September
23rd, 2017, the main events, right?
So, um, from my perspective, the book of revelations is, uh, that's coincidental.
Okay.
Yeah.
So there was a prophetic, uh, uh, that's why, uh, eclipse that came through that year was
prophetic.
My father passed in September 30th and then we had that, uh, eclipse and that eclipse was
the Salem eclipse.
It went through seven.
Yeah.
So if you, you Google it, there were people talking about the time it was called the, uh,
2017, September, 2017 sign in the sky.
It was talked about, um, it's clearly talked about in the Bible.
Um, the, when you look at revelations, right, you've got, uh, seven books or not, not seven
books.
So you have like seven scenarios played out and the first and the last are sort of different
than the middle five and the middle five are sort of a retelling of the same series
of events from a different perspectives.
Um, some people don't agree with that, but that's, that's a common belief that I also share.
Um, and so those, those five, that, that, that five fold vision, um, I believe started in
September of 2017.
So I believe that we're towards the very end of revelations and not the beginning of
revelations, but I don't think it's just seven years long.
It could be like, I think that's an interpretation, but we don't know that for certain.
So I can't say that like, you know, it's going to be, this is the last year.
I mean, it could be three years, you know, um, however, I just notified, I just, uh, clicked
on your bell there.
So I get a notification when you do that.
Cause I would love to hear that.
Yeah, absolutely.
I'm definitely going to save until we get, so what I'm doing is, um, I have a, a non-traditional,
um, view of, of astrology based on the way ancient people used to think.
And definitely, um, not anti-Christian in any sense.
Um, as a matter of fact, I think it's, it's something that, well, you'd have to see those
because I don't want to get into too much, um, but basically, um, it's in line with the
origin of Gnosticism and Hermeticism, but the origin prior to that happening.
So what was, what were people really thinking about these things around the time of Christ
in, in about 50 or a hundred years afterwards.
And that's also the time that astrology really solidified and people had a different way of
thinking.
Um, I don't support worshiping planets and, uh, the planets represent the archons and you,
you find it very clearly in the new Testament that the archons are our enemies, right?
It's not the powers of this world.
It's the princes and principalities of the air, the archons, and that includes the planets.
However, um, that's not, that's not the same thing.
It's so, because that was astro theology and I'll just, and the only reason I'm Catholic
is because you're obviously so much familiar with the new Testament.
So, you know, the word that is translated as astrologer and the new Testament has nothing
to do with astrology, but they had the term astrology in Greek and instead they use the
word mathematician.
Um, so there's no prohibition in the new Testament against astrology that I'm aware of.
Uh, there's a prohibition against mathematicians.
Um, and that's why I was the caveat.
I was always raised that it was, uh, that it was the making up, making up an influence from,
um, the stars that is, is against the world.
I don't, it's like Saturn doesn't, Saturn's not at fault for what you do.
You only, you are at fault for what you do.
Yeah.
I mean, so my position is, is, uh, semi-gnostic.
It would be close to the beginning of Gnosticism at the end of the John and Paul.
Right.
So that would be where I probably locate.
So not a hundred percent conventional, but not like way off the deep end, um, Gnosticism
either, and, um, the planets do correlate with transpersonal cycles of human behavior.
Um, there is in our, from our perspective, there is evidence that the NOS, that the Archons
did that to us.
Right.
And when we use the term Archons, that hasn't been abandoned.
It's just been replaced.
Right.
So people don't say Archons now.
They don't say Demi-Urgent Archons.
They say devil and demons, fallen angels.
Um, right.
So the idea of the Archons, that basic, those basic principles were common at the time of
the origin of Christianity and common amongst or original Christians, whether or not they
were, I'm not arguing against Nicaea.
I'm not arguing against any of that, the canon.
Like I'm not, I would never challenge anyone's personal beliefs.
I would never want to waylay people.
I'm just explaining why I myself am able to make this, this bridge without deep concern.
Right.
And I, I do believe that the Archons, whether you want to call them the God of this world,
the devil, whatever you want to call them, right.
They, they're there and, um, they are, what they did to us is represented in the planets.
So I don't, I don't, um, teach people.
Like I don't do astrology from the perspective of like glorifying the, the transits and the
effect it's the planets don't have an effect on us.
It's, it's us, right.
It's not the stars.
The fault is in us, but we can see it through the motion of the planets, right?
Because we don't have anything.
We didn't have anything else that was periodic over the course of years to see these transpersonal
long cycles in human behavior.
Um, however, those cycles in behavior, those are right.
What is remembered today is, oh no, this guy with the, with the dogs, this is remembered
as the seven deadly sins, right?
And in orthodoxy, it's called the aerial toll houses.
So there is definitely a connection between the, the things represented.
All right.
We have found the truth right now though.
Dude, I'm going to, I can't understand you.
And I don't mean that as an offense.
Um, I don't know what you're saying and I don't know whether you're trolling us or not.
So I think it's best just to, um, just to not do it today.
I don't know if you have a bad connection or whatever.
Okay.
I don't know.
The dog was barking in the background.
I can't really understand what he's saying.
Maybe you guys can.
It's just me like getting old and I can't understand it, but, uh, I think it's better not to have
whatever is yelling involved.
Nothing personal.
Um, argon meal.
Yeah.
So I think it's, it's, it's all the same thing.
And so we look at the, like, we wouldn't narrow down, like what the real sins are that separate
people from God.
Like, why are we in this?
So where I differ from the orthodox position is I think that the reality overlay that we're
in is, is a form of hell.
I do.
I believe this is like Hades, the hell that we forget.
So that's a big difference.
That's very Gnostic.
Um, well, when we get into like, what are the sins, like what is changed in our nature?
What's fallen in our nature that separates it from God?
It's the things that are represented from the Gnostic or from the Hermetic perspective by the
planets that we study that to study how those things, like how that is active within ourself.
And so I look at astrology as a way of seeing one's flaws and becoming conscious of them and
being able to choose, hopefully in some way to mitigate, um, the way those flaws, uh, are
expressed as a way of, of, of being less, um, flawed and, and, and, and not as far from God.
Now, I, I still think you have to be, you know, a Christian, that's my personal opinion, but
I'm not, I wouldn't be surprised if, if there was some, um, loophole there that allowed, but
that's just me.
Right.
But I would never tell someone that, um, yeah, so that, that, that's where I'm at.
I don't like when people go to an astrologer and they want to like know about how they can
do all kinds of things that, that they shouldn't be doing, you know, like I want to know about
all the juicy details of their, of their, um, hypothetical imaginary sex life as interpreted
through astrology.
I don't, I don't do that.
I have nothing to do with it.
Yeah.
That for me, it feels more like, uh, more like tarot cards and recall.
It's just not for me.
It's just not, um, what I do.
Um, I don't consider it to be, uh, I do make predictions about the future and I make some
really accurate ones and really good astrologers always do.
Um, but I don't consider it to be divination because it's, um, it's not, you're not getting
that information from spirits.
Um, you're getting it from the predictable patterns of those would be there either way.
Yeah.
And those don't disappear.
Right.
Um, when we were talking about human nature earlier, we're talking about you, sociality
and human beings as a collective organism on some level at this point, at least.
And those transpersonal patterns of behavior and events are part of existing as a collective
organism.
They're there, whether you see them or not being able to see them as an advantage, in
my opinion.
And if these forces and these forces are both again, right.
Cosmological, right.
These forces are, we can assign them.
We can see them by looking at the planets, but they're not caused by the planets.
Right.
But they were also caused by beings.
They were caused by the beings that we refer to the archons or the, or the fallen angels.
That was how this all came to pass.
Um, you know, I look at it as an opportunity to know one's enemy.
That's, that's how I see it.
Um, I definitely don't see it as a way of glorifying those things.
And I would never encourage someone.
It's also why, right.
I work on a donation basis and I'm upfront with people because I know I don't fit right.
Like why I don't have like a website and super blogs.
And I mean, those guys don't make tons of money, but they do make a lot more money than I do.
And the reason I don't do that is because I, I'm not going to feed into people glorifying
the behaviors and the, and the traits that separate them from God and leave them stuck
in hell.
That's, that's just me.
Like I can't, that's not what I'm here for.
And I'm not going to bear that on my conscious, but you know, we've talked a lot about religion
in a non-religious space.
So if someone has a, um, a non-revelations oriented question, um, or comment or concern
that doesn't involve the dog barking or the guy yelling through the phone or whatever, whatever
that was, I'm sure he's a perfectly good person, but I just, I just couldn't have it.
Morgan, what do you got?
You got anything you've been thinking about lately?
Um, no, you know, it's all right.
I'm just, I'm just trying to break it up.
So it's not just me rambling for fucking three hours, you know, it's okay.
You can say anything.
You'd be like these potato chips taste good.
That's great.
Like just a break for me.
Well, my monotonous voice.
Have you seen anything about Yellowstone that animals are, are steadily migrating?
Yeah.
You know, they've been saying that since the nineties, right?
So, oh man, I don't know if it's true, but let me tell you, they've been saying this
since the nineties.
Yeah, I know.
But they've been doing this since the nineties, right?
Nibiru.
Nibiru has been around the corner.
It's been, it's been on the other side of the sun three months away from since, since
1995 that I can remember.
Um, and Yellowstone has been about to blow up the Yellowstone thing.
Like they do report that the land is rising and I'm not a geologist, right?
I'm not a volcanologist.
But from what I understand, whereas it does have these, these eruptions that cause a lot
of damage.
A lot of the eruptions don't cause a lot of damage.
And there's, um, there's a lot of, um, of ways that, that, that, that Vulcanism that pressure
diffuses.
And what I've been told from people who do study this, who do have a perseverative interest
in volcanology is they're a lot more concerned about the Cascades, Mount Rainer and a Cascades
earthquake, which is connected to Yellowstone through underground magma tubes.
They're concerned about the pressure diffusing there.
I don't know if it's true or not, but that's what I've been told.
So go ahead, Jenny.
Yeah, I wanted to jump up real quick.
I was also seeing the migration stuff.
So I'm from Bozeman, Montana, which I used to skip school and go to, you know, Yellowstone
and do all kinds of stuff.
That was, you know, what I did.
So we're around there.
My daughter's there now and I called her and I said, Hey, tell me what's going on.
And I also looked at some cameras in there.
You can actually see live cameras of, um, old faithful and stuff.
She does not have the same reports.
So, um, there's nothing in the paper around, you know, in, in Livingston, which is in the
Northern entrance into the park.
And I, you know, it could just be sensationalism.
I'm not totally done and finalized on, on asking questions of people I know in the area,
but I just did want to share that with you that, um, I did not receive the, like what
I was expecting.
Like there's a mass, you know, jump out because that's a very good sign.
So I was on it like, Whoa, plus I lived there.
Right.
So I always wondered when I was going to be smothered by lava.
So I think that, you know, I just wanted to let you know that, that so far, some locals
aren't really seeing the same hype, which I imagine they would since they live right all
around the park area.
That's all.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I, I didn't like, we've been going through this, like these scares now, um, since at
least the nineties and who knows, um, who's doing it.
Um, sometimes I think people just want to generate the, the news, um, on a, on a separate
note, I want to let you know that I heard you in a space talking about the drama in, in
UFO, um, X, uh, sometime this week.
And I think that you were, you made more sense than anyone else.
And then you were the only reasonable voice talking about trying to diffuse the rising tension
and aggression and, and all of the things that are happening and, and people reconciling
with each other and, and having compassion and empathy.
And, uh, you know, that really stood out and I was like, wow, you know, I, I don't know
if I've always identified with that person, but now, I mean, I can really say that I identify
completely with what you were saying.
And, um, yeah, and I was, I was very impressed.
Now my being impressed, that doesn't mean anything.
I'm not in a position where I should be telling people, Hey, you know, I don't, I'm not an,
I'm not anyone that anyone would want to impress.
You're, you're just like me and you're human and you have a soul and you care.
And that's all that matters.
That makes you as great as any politician, any leader, any priest.
I mean, so I, it means a lot to me that you notice that cause I mean it and I, I want people
to feel comfortable.
So you do, you're, that does mean a lot to me.
So just so you know that.
Oh, that's, um, well, that's good to hear.
Uh, no, I, I have to be honest that I am doing, um, a session on Saturday, uh, devoted
to, um, I did a session on trying to address the riots.
Rising cognitive aggression in UFO X and how as an outsider or someone recently involved,
it was very clear to me.
And it is very clear to me that there's a looming crisis on the horizon because I've seen this
happen in other communities and I've seen it escalate to the point where there's a big
event and that event sort of changes everything for everyone going forward.
And it's clear that's happening.
And I, I did try to have that and I did try to open up different, um, avenues that that
could happen.
And Doomer came on.
And one of them is of course, what's going on with these wallets really represents, um,
really represents like the next stage of that, um, the hysteria that's, that's coming from
it and the perceptions that everyone is generating of, and I'm not saying that what happened is,
is right.
I'm not.
What I'm saying is that, uh, people are getting involved in a lot of future pacing.
They're getting involved in, um, and getting upset about things they imagine will be done
to them in the future or someone intended to do to them in the future without having any
evidence that's true.
Um, and the reaction is stronger than is warranted by the actual series of events.
As far as we know, although I am seeing a lot of people lost a lot of money in the Rogers
coin.
Um, so yeah, which would be unrelated to buying the domains, right?
Like, honestly, I think a lot of people do that.
They buy domains before a big hit and they make a ton of money.
It's a business move.
I mean, other, you know what I'm saying?
So like, I, I don't even know if I'm on there or not.
I don't really have an issue with it, but I don't know that much.
But it's definitely not something to like start crucifying people over.
Cause that they're very pillar people who have really contributed.
So, I mean, I'm sorry that he had a really good idea and might make money off of it, you
know, and somebody else didn't think of it or he was trying to protect people.
Either way.
They still don't have an admission.
And, um, I like Doomer.
I'm not, I'm not, I think it's, it's becoming more concerning that he's not releasing.
If there's an individual who is doing it, it's not him.
And he knows who that individual is.
It's becoming more concerning that he doesn't release the information.
Uh, I think that a lot of the, the reaction people have is that they're still upset about
the Rogers coin, which was never resolved.
I wasn't here for the Rogers coin, but I've learned a lot about it.
Um, in the last week, a lot, uh, people have contacted me with information and, um, I saw
sort of a clip involving a number of spaces that were held at that time and a number of
videos that were made at that time.
And I'm not an expert in a lot of things, but I have some knowledge and a lot of journals
stuff.
And one of them that I have a general acquaintance with, not personally, but through my life
experiences is with scams and scam artists.
And, uh, as soon as I saw, like, I didn't know anything, but as soon as I saw that clip
and I saw what was going on in the, in the rooms and what was going on with the videos,
it immediately was clear to me that it was a con.
Um, I'm not saying that everyone is going to agree with me, but if you have very little
experience at UFO X and a more experience with cons and scams and griffs, like real constant
scams and griffs, not at the connotation, but what actually happens, that was very obvious.
Um, that was very obvious.
And you are a serious benefit.
I, I do, I cannot, I, I don't know those things.
I don't know why I sometimes get feelings.
I don't want to, but I'm very naive when it comes to evildoers.
I don't think someone's going to, so I just want you to know that, that what we should
begin to do is build some sort of a, you know, a, where it's addressed because it's really
not addressed as well as it could be.
And I think we let a lot of things fly in general and it wouldn't hurt to kind of tighten
it up a notch and raise up a little bit and demand the best out of people.
Right.
And also like people like you to give information who've seen these things.
I don't know.
I still, right.
I wasn't there and people still haven't broken down for me any evidence of what they believe
Doomer did.
And again, I like Doomer and I like to believe the best in people.
And I do believe, you know, then in a lot of senses, he's, there are good things about
him.
I do.
I know that there are people who disagree with me.
I haven't known him as long as they have.
So I can't dismiss what they're saying out of hand.
I can only say this, my experience in the last three or four months, um, or three months
or so of, of knowing him, I, I don't have the same feeling other people have.
However, um, there are other people supposedly involved and I don't know them and I've never
talked to them, but I think those people clearly, you know, without knowing what's going on with
Doomer yet, those people clearly were involved in a premeditated scam just from, from what
I saw based on my opinion, I mean, I never seen him, but yeah, he would have, you know,
you wouldn't have a Rogers.
I heard he, he's the one that rugged because yesterday I think UFO Shane was talking quite
a bit about that.
And I did catch the end.
I mean, I don't want to slander someone.
I'm not a law enforcement agent, so I don't want to, to say what someone is guilty of doing
or not.
I'm just going to say that the behavior that I saw in those videos and in those spaces
was consistent with behavior that I've been aware of from other individuals who were involved
in other scams and the behavior following those events, the disappearing, right?
When he was saying like, I would never rug you guys because I've known you for three years
and I'd lose all my friends and blah, blah, blah.
And then boom, gone, right?
That in my mind, in my opinion, based on my experience is consistent with long con, with
a, with a con that was happening the entire time.
That's just my opinion.
Again, again, you know, when Jake, when Jake was kind of sort of normal, Jake Chansley,
he, he's been going through some things lately.
So I'm not, I want to just say, I'm not really, I have distanced myself for now.
I'm still a support system, but I, you know, I, I can't agree with the things
that he's saying.
I just can't, and I can't, even though he was like my best friend.
But what I'm saying is, is that we were approached to platform them.
So, you know, I made that happen and, you know, Jake does also have a coin.
However, he doesn't even own any of it.
So it's like this thing he's trying to do with just his face and his buddy.
And, you know, granted, if you're, I've also heard from people like Mello, he has a good
point.
Like these things are, are really designed to rug and they're designed to collect cash and snag
it.
They're designed to scan.
Maybe that in itself, there's something to think about.
They are designed to scams, but there seems to be some legal tolerance for them.
That isn't the case in other, in other areas.
So that, that's just what you see in action.
Anyhow, it became all about Rogers and everyone wanted to, to give Doomer a lot of problems.
But in reality, Doomer is not the person, whatever else is going on.
Doomer is not the person that the rising cognitive aggression, the rising problems inside the
UFO community that are very obvious is coming from, it's coming from other individuals who
are allowing and platforming people maybe for views, maybe for their own attainment, whatever.
But it's getting serious and it's getting serious and it's getting serious to the point where
something is going to happen.
If it's not this turning into a lawsuit or a federal investigation.
Like with that whistleblower guy?
I mean, just in general, like this is, well, I think that whistleblower guy, the guy who's
in prison or something, um, that, that's been a very sharp take.
And honestly, um, I'm, I, I'm pleased at that after I heard that he had convinced, I don't
can't even say, I'm not going to say cause I don't know for sure.
But, um, I think that type of, of, of, if, if he really is not who he says he is, then it
is appropriate to say, you know what, you know, you can do your own spaces and have people.
But the problem is this, right?
Somebody comes in with some grandiose idea and they may be scamming and they're very
vulnerable people who are searching for magic.
Like myself, they want to believe.
So it is hard because our lines are so blurred in between gray and white and black because
we know there's something else and we have to, to research that something else to make
sure, right?
So it's very dangerous, I think.
But then again, we can't police thought or belief.
So it's like up to them to fail, which is hard to watch, right?
I've seen that in the last five years in these spaces.
I've watched people kind of get together and then crumble, get together and then crumble
and get together and then crumble.
So it's sort of like you have to play the long game yourself by removing yourself from
click type behavior, meaning everybody's going to go do this.
Hold up.
You know what I'm saying?
Very weird thing we have in social audio to maintain integrity.
Yeah, I mean, I think I agree with all that.
And this was just a long way of introducing the fact that I am going to be talking about
the drama and it's potentially going to introduce, not that I am anyone anyone listens to.
So just in the little corner, you know, I'm going to talk about some issues that I see on Saturday.
And so that may be a small contribution to the drama that I'm making myself.
But otherwise, I agree with you completely about diffusing the situation.
And I just think that people need to be aware of who is stirring them up because it's very
clear who's stirring everyone up.
And those same people are pointing the fingers at everyone else.
Right.
No matter what happened with this thing, no matter how you feel about Doomer, that's not
this is the, this is a result of the crisis.
This is a final stage of a larger crisis.
And if it wasn't Doomer, if it's not Doomer, if this goes away tomorrow, there's going to
be something else.
I mean, in the last few weeks, people have been screaming at each other in spaces and accusing
each other of being evil and all manner of things that are just going to, you know,
metastasize until something happens.
Very evil, actually, like very nasty.
Some of the accusations, I've received some, I broke up with a guy and he's very angry at
me and he is defaming the crap out of me.
And I mean, it's all crazy lies.
It's not even like partial, I'm trying to cover something up.
It's like a flip switch weird.
And it's, it's not, it's very derogatory and nasty.
It's a level of like, so I see what you're saying too.
And it's like this venomous kind of arguing in DMs and threats of all kinds.
I see what you're saying.
And it's almost as if everybody's going to, like the store's going to close.
So everybody needs to grab whatever they can, regardless of what souls they heard before
it's disassembled instead of like barricading the doors, you know?
I mean, I think you're right.
I mean, that situation I would say is an example of, this isn't related to you because you're
having personal stuff you're going through, but it, a lot of people are acting out related
and it's not helpful for people to constantly opine that perhaps they're possessed by a non-human
entity or other escalatory statements.
You know, I agree with you.
I had to talk to Red about that.
When I heard him speak the other day, he was incorrect because I was with, for eight months,
it was slow.
It was getting worse.
It was not just based on that place.
I left before that place, a week before it had progressed for quite some time.
So that specific sky, Skywatcher actually tried to capitalize out on that too.
They had mentioned blood, this, that, and the other one.
None of these stories that, that people seem to be trying to take a narrative out of to get
attention, maybe they're incorrect.
And if you notice, they'll all talk about it, but they will not mention anything of the
fact that I left, I warned people, I have, you know, I communicate with people on the
ranch.
I'm not even mentioned.
Why?
Because I'm telling the straight up truth.
And I think that's a problem with people.
And if you check me, you know, you're going to wreck yourself.
So you see what I mean?
So it's like, but nobody will ask me.
Yeah.
Right.
So that to me was a sign.
I corrected Red.
I said, Red, you know, you really said this.
And I, I, I, I think he's a human.
He's not going to be perfect and he can learn and get better because he is a big, big
member of the community.
And if he needs some learning, he's young, he could use some learning.
I think I just read elections, did a pretty good kind of chat with him on a thread.
I just got done reading it before I came up and it was clear.
It was clear communication, non, like non-threatening.
It was an honest, like you're in your nose before you go out the door or your skirt is stuck
in your underwear.
It's that kind of thing.
We can do that with each other and say thanks afterwards.
Like, cause we want to be better.
Right.
I mean, you would hope so, but I got to say that specifically, you know, I want to,
save this for Saturday, but specifically, um, you know, um, RPK is, is one of the nexus
of, um, the rising problems and confrontation because, you know, he may have said that to
you, right.
And you may have corrected him about that, but he also called the other two individuals
involved, uh, satanic hypnotists and created an entire story about them traveling the country
in the Winnebago, um, taking over people's mind.
Right.
Or they went there to do ceremonies.
It was, it was, yeah, he gets carried away and he's, you know, he has them traveling in
his mind, traveling the country in Winnebago, taking control of the minds of people.
It's very Marvel comics, you know, and if it's not that it's Scientology and it's not.
And, you know, it seems that these, these stories, these storylines, the satanic panic,
the Scientology, and I'm not saying these things don't exist.
What I'm saying is, is that whenever people say, Hey, you know, there's a problem, um, you
guys are creating a lot of drama and it's leading to a crisis.
The way that's distracted or diffused is by switching the topic immediately to, uh, satanic
panic to Scientologists to, uh, uh, intelligence agents and, or, you know, someone called me a
massage massage agent and there's never any, you know, um, there's never any admission.
To the fact of what, what's going on over there.
And it's not even that individual.
It's, you go into certain spaces with certain people hosting the space and you know that
people are going to be there slandering each other.
You know, you know, before you go in, I mean, half, I think half the people go there just
to see people slander each other and it's just not going to go any place.
It's not going to go any place good.
And if this isn't the end of it, it's going to be something worse than this, right?
It's going to be something worse than people freaking out about this list of soul
domains, you know, exponentially worse next time with what, what, what happens.
And everyone is kept apart from each other geographically, which is why something really
horrible hasn't happened.
And, you know, knock on wood, knock on wood.
Well, and I'll tell you what, right now that we're dealing with, um, an issue with a human
being that it could be in HI, whatever, that's fine.
It doesn't matter, but it's a serious issue and it is dangerous.
And, you know, I've been in spaces and I'm not a person that's trying to crucify anyone,
even no matter what they did to me because I'm okay.
And I'm, I'm here, say I'm fine.
I'm not mentally in any, like right now, knock on wood in any trouble.
So I don't mind putting aside everything that occurred to me and saying, Hey, yeah.
Cause I was in a space and he was getting attacked.
Like, like you fuck, like it was evil in my mind.
And it's not helping because we could literally have someone who is unstable, anyone in the
community, including myself.
And as I'm receiving like hate from an individual, I'm getting depressed.
I'm having, I'm like crying.
I'm having to talk my mind out of, you know, this dark place of, of whatever happens, right?
It could happen to anyone.
So we could end up with a loss of life, which has occurred before with anyone being kind of
targeted and harassed or build a false scenario over like you're doing something that you're
not like, this is a medical issue in my mind and only a medical issue.
If it's something else, we can figure that out after it stabilizes, but I can't have, it
could happen in any situation.
So I think that's a hundred percent accurate and you feel it coming.
You're not the only one I've heard it.
So we have to be smart because I've heard people talk about it.
So I think that what you're doing right now is if there's a seesaw and everyone is on one
side, get another route to that seesaw, make a stable environment where people can behave
in a, in a, in a mature manner and can talk about things that are important and that we
like and be that because we need that.
We need another two or three more steady UFO, UAP hosts that are consistent and are always
there so that we can choose and we don't get stuck with drama.
My thing is I'm UFO adjacent.
I'm more of a simulation slash astrology host who just happens to rub up against UFOs all
the time.
But I do intend to keep all drama out of many future spaces.
I just, because I have some experience with this and because I've seen it happen and because
it's, I've rubbed up against it.
You're not a drama guy.
You're not, you're not like sensationalizing.
You're not the inquirer.
You're being like, so, you know, I, again, I understand what you're, what you're saying,
but I will say like, I have to point this out and I will point this out on, on Saturday
and we're going to like talk about different things.
However, it does seem that these switches in the topic of a conversation happen pretty routinely
after people point out that there are a number of individuals involved, uh, people who
we assume run spaces, but we don't know their names because they haven't been released.
Um, right.
Maybe half a dozen individuals who received gifts during the Rogers scenario, gifts of
thousands of dollars, 15,000 to $20,000.
Those individuals may be the individuals who are facilitating some of this drama and the
facilitation of the drama may be related to distracting everyone from the fact that it
hasn't been resolved that half a dozen individuals were gifted 15 to $20,000.
According to what other people say, people who have looked into it, I don't know if what
they're saying is true or not.
I can say that last night I had the misfortune.
Yeah.
UFO Shane said that a bunch.
He got paid $500 every single time.
Okay.
So I'm glad you hear that.
Right.
But see, the thing about that is right.
UFO Shane.
I'm not, I don't know him.
I do know that he likes to put other people down and, you know, talk about how everyone
else is a scumbag.
He might've wanted to check into that before he admitted to that, because if people were committing
a fraud and they were paying him off, not to talk about it, then UFO Shane would be part
of the fraud if there was an investigation.
The problem is, is that he told everybody he would come out of the space and he would
tell, he would say, Hey, they just paid me 500 bucks and not.
Yeah.
So the whole thing is UFO Shane shouldn't be pointing fingers at everyone about how everyone
else is a scumbag.
And he should be worried more about what happens if there ever actually is an investigation.
And he's on tape repeatedly saying that he took $500 payments routinely to not tell people
that Rogers was a scam.
Right.
Because he'll be.
I think that that's what we deal with is people not standing up when they should and watching
something that is wrong happen in front of them and not standing up and saying that's
a big issue in the world.
That is a big issue with humanity.
So I got to switch over to Dan and see what he would like to say and everyone else and
maybe circle back to paranormal and human nature and then talk about the rest of this on Saturday
because I don't want to hijack everyone who showed up here for one thing and then subject
them to the same, you know, the same thing they're going to hear everywhere else.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Dan?
I love it.
And I'll be there on Saturday.
And thank you so much for chatting with me.
I appreciate it.
I was enjoying it too.
So I just wanted to go back to the paranormal a little bit here in the.
Oh, wow.
Sorry about that.
Anyways, I wanted to move back to the paranormal a little bit in the regards of like the collective
consciousness.
And you were talking about this chaoticness that everybody's feeling as, as wars break out
and things escalate.
Have you heard anybody describe it as a vertigo, a feeling of vertigo?
Like we're out on a ledge that we can't walk back from?
And would you relate that at all to like maybe a scientific collective consciousness?
You know, it's quite possible.
I don't know.
I don't want to confabulate and come up with like theories on the spot.
But I can say one of the things about people we don't talk about very much anymore.
We used to talk about in the 90s, you know, glory days, were that, you know, people have
dominant senses.
So some people vision is their dominant sense and it comes out in their language.
They'll say, I see what you mean.
They use a lot of visual metaphors.
And they also tend to be people who visualize very strongly.
There are people who have a strong inner monologue and, and hearing is their dominant sense.
They're audible people.
And so they'll, they'll be, they'll come out in the language.
You know, the people are like, I hear what you're saying.
I'm listening to you.
That sounds good.
Right.
That's their dominant thing.
I can empathize with that.
Right.
So, well, that empathize with that goes to the kinesthetic person, someone like UFO Shane,
who says, you know, in his gut, right.
He smells, which is another kinesthetic sense.
He smells scum.
I smell scum.
I wish I could get a clip of it and play it, but I, I don't have the technology that other
people have.
I don't have that aptitude.
Right.
Well, that's a kinesthetic person.
So I'm just like, I don't want to confabulate here, but if somebody said to me, like, can
you speculate on why this might be the case?
I would say that people are probably sensing what's going on on an intuitive level and processing
it through their dominant sense.
So kinesthetic people, people who have gut feelings and, you know, people who smell scum,
right.
They, I think that that type of person might very well have a vertigo type reaction.
That's just my opinion.
That's speculation.
I'm not basing it on any facts other than the knowledge that people have dominant senses
and the dominant knowledge that all people are intuitive.
Right.
So I think the way the brain works, and this is just me, I'm not a neurologist, but I'm
pretty certain that we keep looking for where stuff is stored in the brain and we keep not
finding it.
Right.
And other people do that.
So when I say we mean humanity, I'm not a neurologist.
I don't think that that's what's actually going on.
I think the brain is an organ of perception.
I think everyone is remote viewing, not in the sense that a remote viewer does, but with a
lot of analytical overlay.
And I think that that's what thinking is.
And a piece of evidence that I would give for that is that they have ascertained now that
human beings don't remember things.
We remember the last time we remember things.
Now it sounds confusing, but if you were in first grade and someone punched you in the
face, every time you remember that, instead of remembering the event itself, you were remembering
the last time you remembered it.
And that's why memories change over time and they're unreliable.
If we actually stored memories in vaults in our brain, we actually had like a little virtual
chemical file that we stored someplace and reproduced.
Our body is very good at reproducing those things reliably, at least until it starts to
break down.
So I think at that point, you'd be looking at memory that would only break down at the end
of someone's life.
It wouldn't be a continuous process as they go through life.
I think that what's happening is that our consciousness, the way our brain works, it's an organ of
perception, it remote views and remote viewing the last time we saw something as opposed to
remote viewing the original event itself.
And we're processing that through analytical overlay.
Everyone is intuitive.
Everyone is going through that.
Their brains are working that way.
And so I think that people who are kinesthetic are probably having these feelings all the time, which
I think some intuitives have, right?
More than others.
I think the remote viewing, like what someone like Morgan does, he goes through intense training
to be able to weed out all of that.
Dominant sense and analytical overlay and judgment, the things that all the rest of us experience
every day that create our worldview from the data that we are viewing intuitively, he's able
to view things intuitively without creating a worldview from it or imposing a worldview on
it, right?
Okay.
So, yeah, I mean, it would make sense.
They're probably, look, I get anxious, right?
Like we all have that stomach sense.
We all get sick around things before they happen sometimes, right?
Haven't you guys have other friends?
It makes me question whether Morgan has ever had his pineal gland scanned.
I doubt it, but let's let him talk for himself.
Morgan, you there, buddy?
Yeah, yeah.
No, I...
Hey, by the way, your thought process just now was amazing.
Like the fact that that take you just had was genius.
Thank you.
I loved it.
Morgan, what do you got?
Have you had your pineal gland scanned?
No.
No, I, you know, I gotta be honest.
I, um, I, um, I approach remote viewing from a practical standpoint.
Um, I, I have very little interest in, um, well, at least in, in being involved in any
kind of scientific studies.
Um, I, you know, I just had this conversation with someone just last night, actually.
And, you know, you, you, you see all over the place, you know, people say, you know, we
need more scientific studies on, on psychic functioning and, and whatnot.
And so, okay, I, I would, to that, I would respond, okay, well, let's, let's engage in a
little, uh, mental exercise.
So, so what would that look like?
Well, I guess to start, you would need, uh, probably a couple of good scientists, physicists,
maybe psycho, uh, psychologists.
Um, you'd probably want to consult with, uh, well, you know, you can imagine all kinds of
different neurologists and everything, but even, but even, even, uh, tricksters, you know,
street magicians, uh, all those kinds of things, because you'd want to.
You'd want to design, you know, a solid, like an airtight kind of an experiment, right?
So, okay, you got to consult with all these people.
Uh, then you need, you need test subjects, you need facilities.
And I mean, if we're gonna, if we're gonna go, you know, strictly scientifically, well,
you're gonna, you're gonna have to experiment in different kinds of facilities with different
kinds of shielding, you know, up to and including, you know, electromagnetic, you know,
Faraday cages.
Um, and then you're going to need to, to run these experiments over, over time and blah,
blah, blah.
And the point that I'm getting at is what am I describing?
Well, I'm describing the SRI experiments that they ran in the early seventies.
Right.
The point is, it's already proven from that perspective.
I, and this is me personally, you know, I'm, I'm all for, and I support any ongoing research,
you know, to, to figure out the how and why, um, uh, how the, how these kinds of things work.
Okay, great.
I do support that, but I'm not interested in being personally involved in any of that.
Um, I'm more of an applications oriented person.
Okay.
So that's a, I guess, a long winded way of answering your question.
No, I've, I've not had my pineal gland, um, scanned nor really engaged in, in any
strictly formal, uh, you know, scientific endeavors, um, with regards to research development,
semi-formal.
Sure.
Um, and that, that said, you know, I, I do endeavor to operate under strict and clean,
um, standard operating procedures with regards to things like remote viewing.
Um, and, and all, all of that kind of procedural stuff, it's all a holdover from, from the early,
uh, SRI days back in, you know, in the seventies through the eighties and, and, and into operations
for, for the military and other agencies.
Um, so that's where all that comes from.
And so, you know, as far as that goes, I, I, but once again, that is from a practical standpoint,
it's just, it's to, it's to, well, as JT kind of alluded to earlier, it's, it's in part to, to kind
of fill, uh, filter out noise, to kind of do what we can to improve the signal to noise ratio.
Um, uh, in terms of using this kind of thing as a, as a practical data collection system.
Um, but yeah, that's, that's where, I mean, my whole, that's why I got into it in the first
place was, I mean, all, all the, all the, the research, all the studies, all the, the SRI
documents and all that are all very, very interesting.
And as I said, I do support further research, but, um, um, I guess maybe, maybe I do have
a number, but you know, uh, I, I, I don't think I would, I would engage in any of that for
yeah, under, under any regular circumstances.
Um, well, you know, who would be the guy Dan would be the guy, man.
If you wanted to scan someone's pineal gland.
Yeah.
Dan, Dan, man, very interested in whether they're correlated or not, because the pineal gland
does emit and receive brainwaves from our bodies and, and we've been dumbed down over the last
century by forever chemicals like fluoride, which tend to collect in your pineal gland and
calcify it.
And children's pineal glands are very mushy and they tend to get a lot more solid and rigid
as you grow.
And if you've had a fluoride in your diet, it happens a lot faster.
And I'm a conspiracy kind of guy who thinks those things are intentional.
Uh, yeah.
I mean, you and everyone else, right?
I mean, that's right.
People wouldn't be in UFO X if they didn't have that predisposition, which is, you know,
I'm not saying you're paranoid.
I'm not.
Let me just, you know, I should probably, I should probably mention for Dan here who's
speaking, uh, and possibly, uh, uh, a handful of people who are listening for clarity's
sake, um, my colleague, uh, fellow remote viewer, his name is Dan.
So I'm sorry, Dan, man.
Yes.
Dan, man.
The remote viewer, um, would be our guy, uh, who I'm not saying he would be interested,
but if someone was to ask me, like, who do you know who would be game for that type of
experimentation, I would say Dan, man, Dave Nice and David Powell, but we're not allowed
to have David Powell, uh, on in these spaces.
So I would get David Nice maybe, or Dan, man, however, that would be something that would
cost money.
Right.
And they definitely wouldn't.
So it's all hypothetical because obviously hypothetically somebody would have to pay for,
right.
They wouldn't be paying for their own pineal gland.
I'm an electrical engineer and I serve a CT scanner.
So if one of them wants their pineal gland scan, they can just, uh, shadow me to work
and, uh, talk to the doctor and, uh, we'll get their brains.
A little like, like, um, in cyberpunk when the people get wounded and they go to the vet
and the vet is the doctor in the back, right?
This would be like a veterinarian with a CT scanner in the back room and you just sneak
him in and you stick his head under it and, you know, you hope it's the right amount of
radiation.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I don't think Dan, I don't, I don't know if Dan would be really up for that necessarily
like the back room CT scan, but I think that, you know, he's somebody who, who would
be open to, and as would David Nice or David Powell.
Like I can think of people, if anyone ever wanted to set up a study like that, the radio
waves coming out of the brain waves or radio waves coming out of the pineal gland and the
connection, potential connection to psychic phenomenon, like telepathy is definitely something
that has been very well-researched.
I'm not sure if that research is so, you know, I'm sure you're familiar with this.
We're in a digital dark age, right?
Instead of conserving information, we're actually selectively getting rid of a lot of information
that isn't showing up on the internet.
And particularly when it comes to esoteric content, there was a, there were an entire
library of esoteric books that were available for sale prior to the advent of the internet
that are no longer available for sale now.
And I only know that because I have some of them and I remember a lot more of them.
There were independent publishers who didn't survive the transition to online sales.
And that information as well as many, many scientific studies, or at least scientific studies related
through journalism, right?
Didn't seem to make it onto the internet as far as we know.
Maybe it's in someone's internet somewhere, but it's just not available, generally speaking,
for us.
So I don't know what remains of that if you were to look into it, but it was definitely
something that was well studied and it was definitely a theory.
I don't think it wouldn't explain remote viewing because there's a level of universal, like I've
followed remote viewing pretty closely since 1995.
I'm not a remote viewer myself, but what I do is I take the information and I break it up
and I, and I put it in my world map, right?
My map of the universe.
And I compare it as time goes on to other data and other information and other information
from other remote viewers.
So I have to keep very close sort of contact to all the publicly available information so I
can make sure that my world map is as, you know, close to, to being right as possible.
I, I, their, their data is pretty universal.
Like if you were to say to me, the pineal gland, could that, the radio waves emitted by
the pineal gland or the brainwaves, could that be responsible for someone's telepathy with
someone in the next room?
Yeah.
Right.
But if you're going to say to me, like, you know, there's a star that they think there's
a Dyson sphere around and intuitive underground looked into it.
And instead of finding a Dyson sphere, the image that came back for them is a giant ship
sticking out of the sun as if the sun itself was a portal and the ship was using it to
transit.
And then it stopped because there was some sort of mechanical failure.
And now I think it's boots, but I'm not sure what the name of the sun star is.
There's a spaceship sticking out of it.
And that's what remote viewers see.
Booties.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Booties.
B-O-L-T-E-S.
Yeah.
Right.
So if remote viewers see a spaceship sticking out of that, that would be difficult for me
to reconcile with the concept of radio waves and brain waves connected to the pineal gland.
I would think that it would be something else.
And from our perspective.
But in laws of thermodynamics, isn't everything connected?
Yeah.
But that would be this time.
This time, time would be right.
I mean, there would be a lot of time transiting from one place to the other.
Right.
However, because we believe that we're in a reality overlay, right?
You may have missed that.
But we believe this is not a simulation, not a matrix, but a reality overlay, which is a
term that we use to explain subtle differences between the three.
But it's along the same lines.
Okay.
So we believe that the universe that we perceive is not real.
It's false.
It's a false perception, series of perceptions.
And that's not just like electronic perceiving.
Well, we believe electronics are involved.
Oh, a mental construct.
Correct.
Like a collective mental construct.
Yeah.
And that there accounts for remote viewing and for a lot of other things, too.
Right.
So the networked brains that make up the, if on base level, our brains are connected and
we're having a collective dream, then you would be able to remote view anywhere inside that
dream without any problem.
However, you can also remote view base level reality.
So it seems that based on the remote viewing data that intuitive underground and other people
have, and Morgan can correct me, but it seems that the first thing when they talk about the
origin of the human race, they, you know, or sorry, I think the report is intelligent design.
Human, the human race is intelligent design, right?
They claim that we were intuitive from the very beginning.
And that may be one of the reasons why we were targeted for inclusion in the reality overlay
is our intuition.
So we may also be able to remote view at base level, but certainly you wouldn't need to
be able to be intuitive in order to remote view inside of a reality overlay, right?
Go ahead, Jenny.
I also have, I've pulled all the studies off of the CIA websites and DIA and kind of followed
it through Monroe.
And, um, the, the one thing that I kind of stood out to me the most is the one called
the analysis of the gateway project.
It's a relatively large paper and I've kind of combed through that with a fine tooth comb.
And one thing that stuck out to me is it said, the mind is like a lamp and it kind of like
a lamp, the way it disperses light.
And with practice and meditation, we can turn that lamp into a laser.
Now with current things about photons and things emitted, you know, we have done, I think if
you could agree, I could grab it and see if you've also seen this, where there are evidence
that we in a way are emitting things out of our pineal gland.
And after I read that, how I saw the world was almost as if I believe in the antenna, right?
I kind of believe we are an antenna to bring in non-locality.
I was seeing it as if, and I kind of practice this in meditation as well, it, as if we were
able to sort of like a laser or say the needle on a record player, we are able to change where
we focus that laser and read the field.
In essence, I'm not talking about materially, I'm talking about things that we can't necessarily
see.
They're so small or packets of light as information.
So potentially, you know, that description to me, being able to be honed like a laser helped
me, you know, kind of consolidate or not consolidate, but reconcile the random number generators
as well as, you know, the observer effect and things like that.
So that was interesting to me in that paper, as well as like the holographic nature of
it, where when we put ourselves into that meditative state, we can kind of detach the program that
makes us limited by physicality, time and, you know, like where everything has its own
home and travel within that space, you know, seamlessly wherever we want, which aligns with
near-death experiences as well, thinking somewhere and being somewhere.
So could it possibly be that it's simply like a, like an ice cube tray?
That's kind of how I could see it, where the ice cube tray itself would be the physical
function.
The water would be the consciousness.
And like those old tiny ice cube trays, you can kind of crack them open and all the
ice cubes come out.
As if we could remove that physical structure overlay like you're talking about.
And then we have kind of free reign from all that is.
I don't know if we have free reign.
However, I think that that metaphor is a perfectly good one.
I don't know.
I mean, I believe Morgan, do you still believe that the reality overlay is, is made of light?
Oh, or, or was, is that still a theory kicking around?
You know what?
It's, I think where I'm at with that right now is again, I will, I will reiterate what
I just said.
Oh, I apologize.
I don't mean to make you repeat what you said.
No, no, it's, it's perfect.
It's fine.
And it's perfectly relevant.
And, um, I kind of have to, to explain my thoughts on it.
So, I mean, you know, again, ultimately the source of all reality, and that would include,
um, very much the, uh, you know, I colloquially we refer to it as the, the, the reality overlay.
It is, uh, as I said, a mental construct now within that mental construct and we'll just
in terms of us here, as we are within the reality overlay and how we experience it, how
we perceive it, but more to do with how we, how we experience things on a day-to-day level.
Well, there are obviously physical rules.
There are physics at play that, that govern the, the function of, of this reality, um,
at a core fundamental level.
Um, all the kind of stuff we're talking about here may very well be valid.
I mean, ultimately we don't understand those, those, those physics to a fine enough degree
to, to really say one way or another.
So, I mean, we're kind of, we're kind of just speculating, but yes, uh, as such the, the,
the concept of what JT was getting at is it's, it's a much longer conversation, but it's this
concept that I've been toying around with for some time that ultimately, you know, light
is, is, is the source of all physical existence.
Um, and again, I, I don't, I don't want to start, you know, swerving off into that lane
right now.
But, um, I guess my point is that sure, all of that kind of stuff is, is completely on the
table, even, you know, with, within the, the, the larger concept or understanding that this
is ultimately a, uh, a mental construct, because again, to operate within, within this, this
construct, we see, we experience what, what, what we can understand and describe as, as physics,
rules of physics.
So, sure.
It's not an either or situation.
It's a, it's probably a both and this and that.
I would agree.
And I think that's go ahead.
Sorry.
No, just, I'm hoping that all made, made sense.
No, it made perfect sense.
As we've talked about, like we, we don't know the exact details of the reality overlay, but
we, we can use reason to come up with a couple of, right?
Like a couple of basic principles.
And one is we wouldn't want to, if we were running this experiment, we wouldn't want to
advance the experiment so far that the data was no longer useful to us.
So we could assume that society has not progressed beyond a certain set, um, a certain set of
progressions from whenever the reality overlay was initiated because the data would become
progressively less useful, um, we can assume that the individuals involved would attempt to use the
data in as many ways as possible.
So we attempt to maximize the utility of the experiment and thus a lot of things that don't
make sense, uh, particularly like the rapid growth in technology, as we were talking about
earlier, um, are explicable when you look at the, the use of the experiment for real world
applications.
Now this not being the real world, this being the world we perceive, but not base level
reality.
So applications at base level reality, right?
We can make certain assumptions about that.
And because we look at this as a mirror, right?
In order to be, to maximize the utility of the experiment, the reality overlay, the matrix,
the simulation, whatever you wanted to call it, uh, we would tend not to use simulation because
it implies entirely within a computer.
Um, but now it does, right?
You would design the experiment, um, in a way that mirrored reality as closely as you could.
So we could assume that a lot of the things that we, we see in our world, we see in this
reality overlay, like a lot of the, um, the physical laws or in this sense, like the, the way that
consciousness might work like with the laser, uh, and light, which is bio photons.
We were talking about that earlier.
It's a hundred percent real.
Um, like all of that could very well be real at base level as well.
Um, it would make more sense.
Like the closer it is to, to base level reality, the more sense it would make.
Um, so yeah, I mean, I, I think this could very well be the actual physics as well, not
just speculative physics, but we're not going to know.
And like our particular focus is more on what do we do as individuals and as a group in the
problem that we find ourselves in now and less on tracking that information.
Like it's possible to track it.
So you could task group remote viewers to look into that information and you could come
up with some pretty definitive answers.
And I'm sure the CIA came up with some pretty definitive answers because they have a lot of
intelligent people working for them, um, or, and have, uh, however, that's not, I think
that's not what we're going to pursue.
I don't know when Morgan can make, you know, Morgan makes the decisions for intuitive on
the ground, Morgan and Dan.
So maybe they'll go to that route.
But I think that our, our focus is mostly on, you know, helping people, um, deal with this
situation and, and what happens after this situation.
So can I say one more time, your brain structure is fantastic.
You can figure things out that aren't readily available and then make a plan.
Like I'm a fan.
Well, so the thing with that is right.
It takes me a while to warm up.
So if you listen to the beginning of the, not that I'm saying you should, but if you did,
um, you know, my brain doesn't work as well as it used to.
So I'm very halting at the beginning.
This is like full drive.
It's like, I've, I've, I've had some hours to warm up.
Um, but I was in a, I was in an accident and my brain doesn't work the way it used to,
unfortunately.
So I need that warmup period.
Um, but I, but I, but I appreciate that.
This is, it's not entirely natural.
It is to an extent, but I, I spent a lot of time and energy trying to, um, without getting
into like bragging, whatever.
Like it's, it's, it's not like, um, like I think a lot of people could too, if they spent
the time and energy developing how to think, um, the way that I did, I think a lot of people
would, would think a lot clearer as well.
Um, so I don't, I think it's a learnable skill.
I don't think it's, but thank you.
I appreciate it.
Um, so yeah, what do we have?
Do we have anything more about the paranormal and human nature?
I think we, we broke down human nature.
We explained how it can explain a lot of the paranormal, but not all the paranormal.
We explained how, what we believe, what, what percentage or what fraction of the paranormal
we believed could be intrusion from outside of the reality overlay and what percentage could
be communication from our collective, uh, unconscious, our, our personal unconscious.
And the collective intelligence of nature, um, and also how some, but not all of the things
we ascribe to the paranormal are actually explainable through biology and basic human
genetic history.
Um, but that definitely doesn't, you know, like not everything that's paranormal is an
archetype.
There are going to be different types of intrusion, right?
There are, the archons can intrude to do completely twisted and evil things, which it seems that
they do.
Um, the same way, um, teenage nerds playing grand theft auto do terrible and unspeakable
things to the NPCs and grand theft auto.
Um, but that's not the majority of cases, but it does seem that that's a real possibility.
In some cases that could explain some of the more extreme evil in the world, um, and some
of the paranormal experiences, but there's definitely room for native paranormal experiences inside
of the reality overlay itself.
Um, and for intrusions that aren't explained by the archons in the reality overlay, like
non-physical entities, which Morgan's data definitely says are real.
Um, I don't know if they're real to the extent that a lot of people would like them to be.
Um, along with the satanic panic and the Scientology situation, um, non-human intelligence possession
becomes a, an easy out.
I'm not talking about anyone's personal situation.
I'm just saying it becomes an easy out.
Like it gets thrown around a lot and it probably shouldn't be thrown around to the extent
that it is because it's more of a tactic, I think in most cases, than it is an actual descriptor
of what is occurring.
However, it is possible.
Um, so that's another factor in paranormal events, but the, the awareness themselves, I
think is, is often the point.
The, the fact that we're unable to understand a lot of what we find when we really look closely
at it is part of the dreamlike nature of our reality.
That is part of the reality overlay, right?
The collective dream.
I think Morgan is moving more towards a dream mental construct, but you know, I would look
at it as dream construct, right?
Because I think that, that that's what is occurring.
I don't think that where this is a conscious mental construct.
I think it's a unconscious mental construct, a collective dream.
I'm not really actually differentiating between the two because to, and for my, for all intents
and purposes, a dream construct is a mental construct.
It's occurring in the mind.
Well, I agree.
It's just that, you know, so the reason I'm making this, I'm parsing this is that I didn't
accept reality overlay at first.
It didn't, it wasn't natural to me, but I wanted to have a, I wanted to have a collective
verbiage, right?
Like a, like a vocabulary that we can use to explain the things that we're learning about
in the data.
So I adopted reality overlay, but it seems that everyone else is moving away from reality
overlay, which is fine.
I'm just trying to parse out exactly what we each mean by things so that we can find like
a set of set descriptors.
You know what I'm saying?
That we're always talking about the same thing at the same time.
And I mean, not again, not to veer off in another, go ahead, veer off any way you want
then.
Well, I'll try and make it quick and see if I can do that.
It's the least I can, it's the least I can offer.
It, you know, and, and you, you pointed out earlier the, the difficulty in, in, um, making
semantical decisions when we're talking about this kind of stuff, you know, because sure,
there, there is a difference.
Well, there's a, there's a shared core concept.
There's a difference between matrix simulation and reality overlay and shared dream really.
But I, maybe I shouldn't use the term, the truth of the matter, but, uh, conversationally
I will.
Um, I mean, uh, our data would basically say it's, it's kind of, it's really all those things.
So it's, I, I don't, and I am often, you know, I'm a stickler for words and definitions and,
you know, words mean things.
So if you're trying to get a point across, we should probably use the correct words.
But when we're in this kind of fringy territory, you can only do the best you can do.
And, uh, you know, as I said, I mean, our data set says really there are, there are components
of all those things, you know, sure.
It, it is.
I think literally, but the best, the best, if it's not literal, it's the best analogy
we can do is that, yes, it's a shared dream.
So, okay.
It's a dream, but a dream is mental.
So it's a mental construct.
This particular mental construct seems to be networked and possibly to some extent regulated
technologically.
So there's your, and there's a power component.
So there's your matrix component and the, the reg technological regulatory component.
Well, there's your, um, yeah, simulation component, right?
So it's all of these things kind of combined is what I'm getting at.
Hey, I agree.
And you know what we never talked about with the doom room?
Um, we never had a chance to, uh, is in the reports on the, um, the report of the origin
of humanities, intelligent design, humanities, intelligent design.
And that report found an intuitive underground.com.
Um, there was a, a suggestion, I believe in what I read now, maybe a while since you read
it, there's a suggestion of the presence of an AI, um, involved in the process.
There's a machine that seems to have some level of conscious awareness and seems to be represented
as a, as a female machine.
Um, from what I recollect, I couldn't be, what up, what's up?
It's the Borg queen.
No, the Borg queen.
Well, I mean, I think that, you know, um, it's in line with, uh, Georgiani.
Now, you know, Georgiani is, um, someone who I would refer to as, uh, a young soul,
a very young soul.
He's a very intelligent individual.
Um, but he's very, he has like, even though he's in his late forties or 50, maybe 50 now
or in his forties someplace, he has the enthusiasm of youth and his mind runs away from him sometimes.
Uh, so as much as he knows, he winds up in some weird places.
Uh, but he talks a lot about the concept of Sophia being an AI.
And I think that may be a valid interpretation based on the, on the, uh, but I don't think
they've done any specific work.
I think there may be an AI involved, you know, this isn't, we're not in a computer.
We're not programs in a computer.
We're networked beings, but I think an AI may be involved in the process of putting it
all together.
That's speculation based on memory of, of reports I haven't read in a while and the
work of other remote viewers and also, you know, historical data found in, in historical
texts, um, what I would interpret to be.
Yeah, it's incredibly interesting because, uh, I ran a project back in, uh, arch I think.
And I just found out what it was and it had, I have not even, I just found out what the target
was, so I literally haven't even, I haven't even had a chance to review my session work,
uh, in, in light of the target reveal to, to engage in, you know, proper final analysis.
But it had something to do with what was, I think the, the, the target was something like
what was, what was that shit?
It was something to do with Elon Musk's, you know, inspiration in pursuing AI and my session
work, I had all this stuff in it about this kind of female presence.
And I kept, I was like AOLing, you know, the concept of the lady.
Okay.
So that's very interesting.
That'd be interesting that the people were here and the people who listen to space who
are, um, part of UFO X, because of course the, the big one right now, I wish fringe was still
here because she's all over this, uh, is the Chris Bledsoe UFO of God material, um, which
I believe is deceptive.
I'm going to say that right from the get go.
Um, however, he had those experiences.
Um, what's interesting is the lady and Chris Bledsoe was popping up in Josh Maitland's, um,
August 9th, um, uh, Astro RV material.
Um, and, um, it's in Chris Bledsoe's material as well.
And of course it's a common theme.
I think there's some, some people in the community who talk about it a lot, the return of the divine
feminine.
Um, I think that from the position of like Jojani, and I think that, you know, I'm not
a Jojani guy, but I'm just saying he had this position as well as we do, um, that this
could be the intrusion of the AI, um, into the, the narrative, um, at the end of this age.
Right.
Uh, so that doesn't surprise me at all.
I think that just based on, on the data, I'm amazed we haven't talked more about this.
I think we have, um, but just based on the data that I S I've seen from other remote
viewers, uh, based on my understanding of the historical data from, um, the Gnostic Christians
and, um, and, you know, based on, on your data, uh, it would seem to me that, you know,
I know that the, the quote Demiurge is DNA, right?
The collective DNA, which is one mega organism.
And it's the Lego building blocks inside the reality overlay.
Um, it wouldn't surprise me if, you know, the concept of Sophia was the AI governing the
whole process of the overlay itself.
Right.
And that would make sense.
However, it could be something that's happening at base level reality, right.
Or something that happened above and beyond base level reality.
That was like, cause we talk about this, like this is levels.
And we're at the very bottom, uh, here we're at the lowest level of, of this pit there.
And there are a number of levels of reality, which you might call planes of reality, or some
people might call them.
Did we lose the house?
Uh, you know what?
It looks like we did.
Um, it's happened before.
I'm sure he'll be back in 10, 10 to 30 seconds.
I bet.
Okay.
There we go.
Then let me reconnect without a cohost.
So that's great.
I don't know how that happened.
Uh, I'm amazed.
They waited to this point to fucking bump me.
Cause they usually do it like three times at the beginning, but I guess I wasn't saying
anything crazy.
So this is like a nested Russian doll reality, right?
That we're in and we're in the tiniest little Russian doll, um, of them all.
But there are other realities around us above this one between us and an origin source.
Um, base level reality would be the next level.
And this is something that's in Morgan's work, but it's also found in the ancient Gnostic
texts.
Um, and, uh, I think it's found pretty much everywhere, um, that these other levels of
reality are, are real and they're above us.
And we encounter them.
If we can get out of the situation that we're in now, the reason that we're not encountering
them directly, particularly after we pass on in the world is that we're trapped in a,
um, in a situation we can't get out of.
Um, but the goal is to get out of it.
And once we do, and once we're back in base level reality, and I don't think that's something
that can happen in life.
Um, then you're confronted with the various levels of reality before you get back to source.
And I think the Gnostics would say, um, well, the Hermeticists said what seven, right?
And then the Gnostics have between 12 and 31, depending on which book, you know, as time
goes on and things get further from the original, um, the original base philosophy, the way people
think changes.
And so they have to confabulate a lot of information to try to make what people originally said make
sense to them because they no longer think the same way.
And they are not taught how to learn, how to think like people did in the past, which
is how it should be done, but it's not been done that way because people don't have that
skillset.
Um, and that's something that I've adapted when my study of astrology was trying to teach
myself to think the way that people thought at the dawn of the age of astrology, as opposed
to taking modern thinking and superimposing it on that.
Um, go ahead, Jenny.
Uh, are you guys sure it's not because you're boys and you're nervous.
It's a woman.
So you're going to call her a bad guy.
I'm totally kidding.
I'm just kidding.
But I, something interesting the year before last Haley, I wish I could grab her last name.
She did a presentation at, um, I believe it was the cosmic summit.
She travels and she does a lot of ancient, um, uh, well, like hieroglyphs, et cetera.
Young girl, really intelligent, neat, neat girl.
She and Randall Carlson talking about like the repetitive sort of resets.
She had mentioned something before of, of basically previous civilizations had had a different route
of belief and it may have had both, um, male and female and some point in time that was
female.
And so that was interesting to me that, um, that had been something perhaps that we had
seen previously.
And somebody also said something about how the Catholics, as they kind of honed in, no, no
offense on Catholics.
I would say the Catholic church or their administrators had honed in on like kind of a power core
that they couldn't get rid of Mary because she kept coming back.
So not that I think those things are accurate by any means.
And AI is a penetration into our reality for sure.
And we are not going to know what a new thing looks like.
It's going to appear and it's just going to, you know, this is new to us.
Right.
So I thought that was a little bit interesting as a woman, not that I'm any way feminist
or whatever.
I love men.
They're fantastic.
And I wouldn't be alive without one is that potentially like, because of the capitalization
of this hierarchy of the Abrahamic religions and sort of separation that, um, potentially
I kind of thought, well, Hey, I bet she may come back if there was such a thing because
there's an imbalance.
Not that I, you know, I'm in no way trying to push men down because literally you're, you're,
you're, you're a structure and everything.
So, but together we're the best.
I, I, I found that a little bit interesting to me how she also was talking about the fish
symbol that way back in the day, the fish symbol was actually like a feminine in these
previous civilizations of like a vagina, which I know that's really kind of pushy, but at
the same time, there's a lot of stuff where you can, she's shown it.
I do have her videos broken down, um, from two years ago.
She will come into spaces and talk.
She's an interesting gal.
So I'll, I'll, um, stick them in the pill just as some, you know, neat to look at.
Cause I'm also very interested in this incoming sort of, you know, whatever it is, cause we
can be psyoped and they're damn good at it.
So I appreciate you guys digging into that.
Yeah, no problem.
I'll take it from the beginning there.
Uh, no, not nervous about having women in the space or letting women talk.
And we don't call on women more than men or men, more than women.
It's really not relevant to us as far as I know, at least I can't speak for Morgan, but
it's not relevant for me.
Uh, it's just about spreading the ideas.
Um, I don't, I don't know about the, the divine feminine.
Like I'm not, I'm not, I'm not against, um, I'm not against anyone's ideology really, um, or cosmology.
My concern is almost monomaniacal and always comes back to the same thing.
And that is we're in a world filled with tremendous, uh, suffering.
Um, we create the majority of the suffering.
Um, we're, we're programmed to do that.
Um, we have an arconic nature, um, no matter how good things get, we just keep recreating
a hell for a certain percentage of people.
And eventually we all fall into that situation. And then we die. And if we're materialistic and we're focused on life and the minutia and the everyday, and also if we're focused on cosmologies and ideologies and gender issues and sex issues and geographic issues and tribal issues,
and that takes us away from the two things that I believe we should be focusing on. And one is alleviating the suffering of the people while we're here. And two is preparing for death so we can try to prepare to escape the situation.
So for me, my concern isn't whether people want to worship the divine feminine or not. As a Christian, I wouldn't recommend it because it's just not what we believe. However, I don't personally, it's not an issue between me
and the concept of the divine feminine. It's, I don't want distractions and intrusions that are designed to, you know, waste our time when we only have so much time in this world to accomplish the things we're supposed to accomplish and get ready for the next step.
And I see pretty much everything that happens in that light. I see all manner of distractions as simply distractions. And I just sort of dismiss them for me, but I don't dismiss them for other people and other people can follow them as, as closely as they want.
And this is actually, you know, Morgan and I are friends and, um, but we became friends through this work and me finding intuitive underground and Morgan approaching me to work with him on the Astro RV project. It was synergy. Um, it was something that I believe was meant to happen, uh, because I do believe that we come into this world, um, with an appointment to meet certain people to accomplish what, or not accomplish.
Our, our, our, our, our side mission in the world, our human mission in the world, um, in this lifetime.
And I do believe that exists to an extent. And I think we meet people who facilitate it and teach us things we need to know, uh, and vice versa. Um, however, Morgan and I have very, a lot of differences of opinion, um, about how we approach life.
And so we run into that type of stuff as well. Like even two people who are trying to spread the same information, even two people who are, you know, privy to this similar data. We still, at the end of the day, um, are divided ideologically or by our basic predispositions and our, and our manner of thinking.
So it's, it's not avoidable. Um, but I just think it should be minimized to the greatest extent possible so that we can focus on, you know, both alleviating the suffering of the people who are here and trying to get those of us who can get out of this situation out of it, if it's possible. Um, and, and that's really preparing for death, which is something that all distractions are designed to keep us from thinking about our death and our mortality.
Um, low hanging fruit. I get it. I get it. That was fantastic. Again, dude, love your brain. I'm not, I'm going to be quiet. I'm just, I literally mean, I'm kind of like a brain searcher. I like gold pan for brains and yours is awesome. No, I should be quiet. Cause it's a weird thing to say, but your structure is beneficial because it synthesizes information in ways that we can use it. So I think that your existence here is vital because it's a perception that is understandable and it lays out in such a beautiful way.
I'm going to stop now. I put a lot of work into it. So I appreciate the recognition of the, of the work and my success and being able to do it.
We definitely need more people above the curve.
Yeah. Amen. I don't know. I mean, I think that, um, I think that the first thing to do is to try to get away from, you know, not to make this about that again, but try to get away from, um, people whose judgment is sort of disconnected from their own personal realities.
Um, and people who are, uh, looking for entertainment at the expense of, of other people on the communities that they're, um, Involved in.
And I think that that's where you start and, and where you move forward to is really dependent on where everyone wants to go. Right. It's like a, at that point, it's sort of a collective decision of what everyone thinks.
What everyone thinks is, is, is appropriate. Um, but you have to have a, before you can move forward anywhere, you've got to have a starting point. And just because something has been around for a while, it doesn't mean that you're at that starting point.
It doesn't mean that you've completed the formulation process, the beginning, you know, everyone mixing together. And, um, I think that one of the ways you could look at this oncoming crisis for UFO X. And again, I'm an outsider, but I've seen this happen in many communities.
And I'm, I'm, I'm very certain it's happening here is, uh, is a blow off prior to a reformulation, right? A reset of its own sort. Um, you know, it's nature is fractal, right?
So the same way that we have resets in the, in the world that we think about a lot, those of us doom and gloomers, um, you know, there are resets in communities as well. And it, whatever is going to happen, whatever the crisis is like, it's, it's going to be regrettable. Um, however, hopefully people will take from that. Like, let's get back to thinking and thinking about how we think, which is, I know sounds like an asshole thing to say, but it's, you know, I think didn't Biden say that I'm not getting politics into it, but think about what you're thinking.
Think about, but he was right. He was right. Everyone laughed at him about that, but it's really like this thinking. And there's also thinking about how you think about things and, um, you know, drilling down like that.
And then approaching those subjects again and saying, what do you see? Right. And I think that's just as accurate with the UFO phenomenon as everything else. Like, is there something? Yes. Are there a lot of things? Yes. Are there a lot of things that people group together into one? When it's the paranormal, do people try to come up with like one unified theory inside the reality overlay,
as opposed to looking at it from the holistic outside the reality overlay, they absolutely do. And when you do that, you, um, like you create imbalance. I think as, uh, as Jenny was saying, you create imbalance, but intellectual imbalance. Um, and then the way that is resolved is through conflict and people fighting over their particular take on, on what is and isn't real. And again, then you get the people who just pile on top of, want to make money off of you. Right. You got the coachman who want to, want to sell ruggers coin.
Right. And then you get the, um, you get the people who like drama and trouble and they live a sort of a lonely, empty existence. And you get the people who don't live in only lonely existence, but they're kind of sadistic. So then they come in and they get into a community and they kind of cause trouble. And it just drives people away from the, the point. And we're, we're, we're not going to focus too much on that. Um, you know, we're going to do this maybe one on Saturday, maybe one more, another time, but mostly we're just going to, um, go forward with these,
uh, Thursday ones. I think the next one is going to be, I'm pretty sure. Unless Morgan has an objection. I think this is one he's wanted for a while. We're going to talk about, um, because we always talk about history, right? So we're going to talk about Terrence McKenna and his more time wave zero model of the universe leading up to this current period of time.
And, you know, right around 2012, but the early two thousands to this period of time. And we're going to talk about alternative reality games and how someone came up with the idea, um, that the best way to manage society is to create alternative reality games.
That let people sort of live out a fantasy, um, and entertain them and entrain them, but also shepherd them to have their energy used constructively and to have them come to the conclusions that one would want them to come to.
So some examples of this would be, um, or, you know, there were some early examples prior to 2012. And then in 2012, we had a real game, an actual alternative reality game that's still played today called Ingress.
But in that time you have had it adapted. What was learned from those weapons.
They turned that into Pokemon.
Well, Pokemon is still there, but Ingress is still there too. I know this because I'm an native player.
Yeah, they use it to create the Google maps.
That's cool.
Which they fell to the intelligence services, right? So it's all, it's all connected. It's gamification. It's the harnessing of people for, it's harnessing people's energy and leisure time and entertainment for purposes, um, that the people themselves aren't aware of.
That's what alternative reality games are. And one of them happens to exist in this community right now.
And that's a fact. And you get Q, Reddit, 4chan, you got those online ones. You've got, uh, what is called LARPing, right?
In, in the UFO community is an alternative reality game. It's the, the two are interchangeable.
Um, but it just became the dominant mode of sort of managing society. And I'm here to say, like, first of all, it's not a bad idea.
Um, because it's a lot better to have, uh, that as your mode of managing society than having outright conflict.
Uh, previously as your mode of managing society. However, it has ramifications.
Um, so we're going to talk about like the history of games. We're going to talk about the, the history of novelty and habit, and then alternative reality games and like what we can learn about them.
Um, and maybe, you know, how we can consciously approach them. Um, because there's something that is in the periphery, especially in a community like this all the time where you find these LARPers and you find the, the quote bot accounts.
So now particularly with, um, AI, which I don't know if I'm going to get bumped when I say this, but you know, AI is the central mitigating, um, uh, managerial force to the modern alternative reality game, um, genre.
A lot of them are being kicked out by AI on an individual level, but we can also speculate that they're probably being managed by AI in a centralized sense as well.
Um, so we're going to talk about that next Thursday, uh, Saturday I'm doing, um, Morgan doesn't do Saturday. He's got other stuff. He does a remote viewing one.
And if you're interested in remote viewing, you should choose his over mine because mine is about UFO X drama and you live that every day. Right? So you should definitely, if you're interested in remote viewing, you should go to Morgan's remote viewing. Um, if he has one on Saturday, a hundred percent, and you're not going to find a better teacher.
He talks about himself being utilitarian. He talks about himself in a lot of ways like that, but that's exactly what you're looking for when you're looking for a teacher or when you're looking to hire someone, you're looking for someone who is, you know, has mastered the basics and has moved that craft forward.
Rather than someone who's often left field. Right. And you never know what you're going to get from that individual, regardless of what the natural gifts are. So you're going to want to do that first, but if not, come over and we'll do, uh, uh, UFO X drama and what's going on and who's kicking out the drama and what's going to happen if it doesn't stop. Uh, et cetera. And then next week, um, I'm going to do a series. I'm going to begin a series of, uh, daily short spaces on astrology.
And I approach astrology as, um, an analog simulation model. I don't think the plants cause anything. Um, but I do think the archons are responsible for the traits of the planet's track. Uh, but it's simply, um, simply a timing mechanism, a map. And, um, we're, I'm going to do some of those. Um, and I'm going to approach a planet at a time.
So, you know, on Tuesday, someone was asking about the eighth house. So on Tuesday, I'm going to talk about Mars. I'm going to talk about Aries and Scorpio and the first and eighth houses and the central concept being objectification.
And so we're going to go through that, how it plays out in astrology. And then what we can learn is like people from studying our own astrology or our familiarity with it about how we objectify others and how others objectify us.
And maybe how we can do that a little bit less. Um, I might start Sunday with the sun, which is the arrogance of the ruler and the area in our lives where, cause we each have an area in our lives where we're, we're arrogant.
And, you know, people might like the spotlight might be on us in that area, but a lot of people might not like us very much at the same time, um, because we hog the spotlight in that area and we might not be exactly who we think we are and, um, and, and how to address that.
Right. So that's the hermetic and Gnostic and original Christian sense that they looked at the planets and the effects of the planets.
And I'll go through that every day with other short ones. So it's, it's not going to be a hundred percent UFO stuff. It's not going to be like,
uh, tremendous attraction. I think for a lot of people who are into UFOs and we're looking for the UFO drama, but people are always, uh, welcome to stop five for the spaces.
And I will cover UFOs to the extent that I can, when it comes up, UFOs are included in astrology. There is a, there is an astrology of UFOs.
I might go over that on Saturday because we can also track the drama by using the, I, I wanted to think about it and approach it from an astrological perspective.
So I thought about, um, how I would look at the UFO X community astrologically.
And I determined that I would probably use the Roswell event as the chart, the natal chart, look at events.
And I tested it against some of the events that have occurred in the last year with the ruggers coin.
And, um, it does seem to fit.
And I think I can make some preliminary predictions about how it might play out and when, and if that's the case and it works, then we'd know that the Roswell incident is the chart for modern ufology.
And, um, but there's, there's another earlier chart that tracks like aliens and we can use it to predict when and how and where, um, alien stuff and ufology is going to pop up and be how people are going to think about it.
And, um, and there's another astrologer, a decent one is not, not a friend of the space, not a friend of mine, Dan waits, but he's, he's very competent.
And he did a series of videos called the age of Gemini, about seven, two hour videos, um, starting in the late 1800s and talking all about the UFO phenomenon and how it relates to technology and how it relates to, um, a cult stuff.
And, you know, Aleister Crowley and Jack Parsons and all those individuals.
And I think he probably touched on Scientology as well.
So there'll be something there for red pandas, marijuana induced paranoia.
Um, and I will link those all seven, if I can put them, if I can figure out how to do it, I will put them in the pill on Saturday.
If anyone wants to get a thorough in-depth idea of what's going on with the UFO phenomenon as a phenomenon itself, as opposed to individual experiences.
So we'll go forward like that and see what happens.
And anyone is welcome to join us.
Um, I usually have to go at seven o'clock.
I don't tonight.
So that's why I'm winding down slowly.
Morgan, what are, what do you have?
Um,
Going on, dude.
Well, um, yeah, um, I don't think I'll be running an RV space on Saturday.
Uh, if I, if I do on this weekend, it'll be Sunday.
Um, and I'll, I'll try and post it, uh, a couple of days ahead of time.
So that, well, that doesn't leave me much time now, does it?
Uh, in any case, if I don't get to it this weekend, definitely it'll be, uh, the following.
Um, I try to run them once to twice a month.
Um, I'd like to do them more regularly, but, uh, it's a, it's a matter of, you know, availability.
So, yeah, I'll, um, I will be running one soon and I will post, uh, as soon as, as soon as I, uh, can pin that down.
Well, you can always come by on Saturday, listen to me talk shit.
And then, uh, with a little astrology, uh, spiced into it.
Yeah.
And, uh, some discussion of cognitive aggression and primal aggression and how aggression escalates and what's likely to happen.
And, you know, some basic predictions about how this shit show with our Solana accounts is likely to play out, uh, et cetera.
But also challenging some individuals whose spaces are habitual incubators for, um, for, um, what's the word I'm looking for?
Slander.
Slandering of other people for the sake of entertainment.
Well, I've been saying, I've been saying it for a long time.
I mean, I'm, I'm very much like yourself.
I'm not involved in, in, in that end of things.
I mean, you know, we, we kind of tend to get lumped into, to UFO Twitter because things like, you know, remote viewing and astrology and some of the related topics that we talked about kind of, you know, from, you know, I guess the majority's perspective.
All that kind of stuff falls under the same umbrella.
It's all just, it's, you know, it's the weirdos, right?
The weird people that are into the weird stuff, like, you know, and that's fine, whatever.
Um, but no, I, I, um, I mean, I'm going to, I'm going to stay away from, from that involved.
I'm not currently.
So why the hell would I want to insert myself?
Exactly.
You know, drama is a term that we use to dismiss other people's pain when we're desensitized to it.
If it happens to us, it's not drama.
If it happens to us, it's an important situation.
It's a dangerous situation.
It's a, it's a impending crisis.
If somebody else is talking about it, we're disconnected from it.
We're desensitized to it.
Well, then it's drama.
And so when you get into a community like this and they're like, oh, well, there's all this past drama and you hear these stories.
If you're not connected to the community, if you're not desensitized to it, you're like, oh my God, what?
Well, yeah, but really, you got to think about it in the context.
What, what's another word that you, that you could replace drama with, uh, entertainment.
It's entertainment and I've been there for a long time and that's, and that's exactly why, I mean, before, before the drama really started to, you know, escalate and start to boil over.
Like it sort of has been, but I mean, to be fair, it's kind of been there before.
Like, I mean, I was a long distance observer of, of at least, you know, some of the, some of the Rogers stuff that happened a while back.
And, you know, I, you know, again, it, it, it calmed down and, um, my, my point is it's, it's an ongoing drama and I would say it's, you know, comparable to, it's like a soap opera.
And I really think that's, that's exactly what it is for a lot of, a lot of the observers and probably a certain amount of, of the active participants.
It's basically just, it's entertainment, you know, um, UFO stuff is kind of secondary.
It's incidental.
This is the type of thing though, Morgan, this is the type of series of events and games that everyone finds entertaining until someone fucking freaks out.
Right.
And then they all disavow it and say, Oh, you know, I, I had nothing to do with that.
Apparently there was someone involved in UFO X who, who did some terrible things.
Um, and that apparently did not dissuade everyone from, from getting, you know, continuing on, um, after, you know, uh, I think that we've discussed this, but why not have, um, after Saturday, um, you know, I'm going to explain why I'm going to people are welcome to follow us.
And I encourage you to follow Morgan and, uh, follow me.
If you'd like to learn more about the spaces, uh, you don't have to follow me.
You can follow Morgan and cause he's going to post about the spaces.
Right.
Um, we're not trying to, you know, follow anyone you want to, uh, thank goodness.
I don't have to.
Oh my goodness.
I'm just kidding.
Oh, so, um, you know, but it's after like, just trying to break this down and make some predictions because it is, uh, you know, we have, I wound up on the list, right?
I am a stensively part of UFO X next I'm, I'm on the list now, I should say, right.
I'm on the UFO X list.
So in some sense, I'm part of the community and this is just my, you know, I'm not, um, going to be stoking things.
I'm going to just explain my, my perspective on it.
And then, um, you know, I got to make some decisions about who I'm going to follow and in what spaces I'm going to join, because I don't want to give my energy to what is going on in some of these spaces.
So this is a chance to, to, to do the right thing and then to move forward, um, knowing that I'm, I'm going to have to, as you know, I, I, I am a human being too.
And I fall into the turn it on, listening in the background to get entertained.
And I think we all like, we all, or a lot of us were drawn for entertainment, not to see other people's pain originally.
Um, but I think that maybe there's, there's a little pain harvesting involved, but I think we all have a soft spot in our heart, but also we get a little entertainment out of the people who are really quixotic and eccentric and who have really quixotic and eccentric explanations.
I think a lot of us kind of jump up when someone sits down and says like last Saturday, when a guy came in, I think it was young, a kid came in and he said, you know, um, the government used a laser to destroy my soul.
And, um, now I can't see atoms.
And so I can't get to the universe before this, but I've learned a lot about aliens and I want to share it with you.
And he was all into it.
Like he wasn't upset.
He wasn't crying or anything.
He was super psyched about sharing the information he's gained about reality from his experiences.
Now it sounded terrible to me that, you know, to say that someone had used a laser to destroy his soul, but that was his, I don't know.
That was his story.
Right.
But it's that type of like quixotic story that kind of outside of story that I think a lot, what was that?
Go ahead.
Sounds like his dark materials.
I guess maybe, maybe that's where he got it from.
I don't know.
Um, all I'm saying is, yeah, you know what?
Very well could be that he was doing a book.
That's, but that's like the, the real type of entertainment, right?
Not entertainment that, that harvest people's pain and suffering, but entertainment that goes along with like the, because, so that's what draws you in.
But then you do get sucked in the Jerry Springer drama and then you do like, you know, and I can't, I can't participate in that.
So, um, Morgan, I think is important is, is, uh, I'm not putting thoughts in words in his mouth, but you know, I think it's to see this as a, as drama harvesting.
And that's not what I'm trying to achieve at all.
Although I can say that I had a 700, almost 800 people in the last space.
So it was the most successful space that I've ever done.
So I guess in a sense I was drama harvesting, but I don't intend to do it as a weekly thing.
I'm not going to get involved in talking shit about people every week.
I just want to complete what I started last week.
Go ahead, man.
Here, here.
It's saying I was, I was joking, but only.
Oh, I know.
Yeah.
But it's, you know, what's a joke.
That's funny, right?
What's the equation of comedy pain times distance, right?
You measure like the things you feel pain and then the distance you feel from the event.
And that's what makes it funny.
And you're right.
It was a joke and it was funny, but it's also something I kind of have to address because I'm telling people, look, I'm, we're doing these spaces.
It's not about drama, but I'm going to do a space this Saturday that has UFOX drama story hour in it.
And there may be another one after that, right?
And so I'd be lying to people if I didn't just break it down exactly what was going on.
And, you know, part of it is me breaking my addiction, right?
If I, if I piss off red panda, koala, and, and people like that, and I'm not welcoming their spaces anymore, then you know what I won't have a temptation to do?
To go into their spaces and sit there and listen while people slander each other and laugh about it, right?
So it's a win-win situation for me just to get it off my chest and to try to, you know, be on record as saying, hey, this is what's happening.
This is when it's going to happen if you don't stop, and this is how it's going to affect you and, you know, and have this one not be about people shouting at Doomer.
There's not going to be anyone shouting at Doomer this Saturday.
They've already got it off their chest, and that situation is going to be whatever it's going to be, right?
So I'm not going to bring him up and have him, have people just sit talking.
This is going to be about just the general issues.
Hey, look, hold on.
My, my phone is about dying.
Man, I plugged it in, but I don't think I can get him from another device onto this before this crashes.
So I got to wrap this up.
Dan, this is going to be like the last few seconds.
I'm sorry to wrap it up abruptly, guys.
That's fine.
I was just going to say I got to go, so I, but I didn't want to dip out of the space.
Hey, cool, man.
Good to talk to you.
Hey, cool.
And I hope I see you in future spaces.
I hope I see all of you in future spaces.
Thank you for sticking out with us for four and a half hours in some cases.
And thank you for your kind words, Jenny.
And everyone else, it's good to see you.
And I hope that I'll see you, if not on Saturday, if you want to avoid the drama, I hope next Thursday or during the week.
If you ever had any questions about astrology or, you know, then you can certainly come to one of those spaces as well.
I can't wait for that.
I'm going to go there.
That whole geometry, like the whole, yeah, I'm excited you're doing that.
All right.
Well, then I look forward to seeing you all.
I'm going to end the space now.
It's going to be about like 10 seconds of silence because that's what I was told to do.
Thanks.
So, all right, guys.
You as well.